on sera tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour cette nouvelle édition spéciale de
celle 1 360 voici mais les quittera le
sénat dénonce des dysfonctionnements
majeurs au sommet de l'état après sept
mois de travaux la commission d' enquête
sur la sphère benalla a présenté son
rapport et 13 préconisations pour en
finir avec les collaborateurs officieux
et assurer la sécurité du président de
la république le détail dans un instant
et dans leur rapport à les sénateurs
estiment qu alexandre benalla doit être
poursuivie pour parjure tout cas vincent
kraz soupçonnée d'avoir menti sous
serment
ils ne sont pas les seuls les cas
d'alexis colère patrick strzoda et du
colonel lavergne sont aussi dans le
collimateur pour rétention d'information
des explications à suivre la réponse de
l'elysée n'a d'ailleurs pas tardé à
l'issue du conseil des ministres
benjamin griveaux porte parole du
gouvernement a répondu à la mise en
cause du sénat il évoque des
contrevérités l'elysée aura l'occasion
d'apporter des réponses factuelles at il
a déclaré vous l'entendrez dans cette
édition
et je vous rappelle d'ailleurs que vous
pouvez réagir sur twitter avec le
hashtag à senna 360 pour m'accompagner
cet après midi on retrouvera alexandr
poussard en direct de la salle des
conférences pour l'érection des
sénateurs à ce rapport sur la sphère
benalla dans notre multiplex politique
et parlementaire tout de suite
le verdict du sénat était très attendu
et il est très sévère pour l'elysée dans
un rapport de près de 150 pages les
sénateurs pointer les défaillances de
l'état d'une présidence qui a péché par
manque de précaution notamment sur la
question des contrats russe contractée
par alexandre bédat l'a13 préconisations
sont ainsi formulé le détail avec
aurélien romano de graves
dysfonctionnements au plus haut niveau
de l'état c'est la principale conclusion
du rapport de la commission d'enquêté
sénatoriale sur la sphère benalla pour
les sénateurs la sécurité du président
de la république a été affectée par la
présence d'alexandre benalla à ses côtés
son manque d'expérience couplée à la
place excessive qu'on lui a laissé
prendre au tour d' emmanuel macron sont
des erreurs majeures
la thèse de la faute de l'homme isolé
s'est effacé au profit du
dysfonctionnement d'une institution qui
a rendu possibles ces multiples
situations normales allant jusqu'à
affecté je crois que jean pierre sur
l'a10 très bien la sécurité du président
de la république il n'y a pas une seule
affaire pour les sénateurs mais
plusieurs affaires qui révèle tout des
dysfonctionnements la sphère des
passeports diplomatiques avec les graves
lacunes concernant leurs attributions et
surtout leur récupération
le cas des conflits d'intérêts avec le
contrat russe signé par alexandre banana
alors qu'il est encore à l'elysée
en conséquence les préconisations de la
commission sont multiples prévenir et
sanctionner les conflits d'intérêts
parmi les collaborateurs des cabinets
pour qu'il ne soit dans la main de
personne
garantir le respect des standards de
sécurité les plus élevées en ce qui
concerne la protection du président de
la république et celle du premier
ministre
mieux encadrer la délivrance
l'utilisation le retrait des passeports
diplomatiques et de service
faire en sorte que les promotions dans
la réserve de la gendarmerie nationale
soit mieux réguler et plus généralement
veiller à ce que les collaborateurs des
autorités politiques n'interfère pas
avec le fonctionnement opérationnel des
administrations ceci est un point
évidemment très important parmi les
treize propositions de la commission
près de la moitié concerne le
fonctionnement
l'exécutif est particulièrement le
recrutement l'encadrement et le contrôle
des collaborateurs de l'elysée
les sénateurs souhaitent aussi renforcer
les pouvoirs de contrôle du parlement
sur les services de la présidence de la
république
enfin les sénateurs demandent est ce que
la justice se penche sur les
déclarations mensongères d'alexandre
benalla ainsi que sur certaines
omissions des collaborateurs de l'elysée
auditionné
nous proposons au président du sénat et
au bureau du sénat de saisir le parquet
c'est clair premièrement pour monsieur
benalla écrase en parlant de faux
témoignages deuxièmement nous demandons
que pour les collaborateurs de l'elysée
précités le parquet soit saisie au nom
d'omissions d'incohérences et de
contradictions et au nom du fait que les
personnes concernées ont retenu une part
significative de la vérité à la
commission parmi ses collaborateurs
figurent le directeur de cabinet du
président de la république patrick
strzoda ainsi qu alexis colère le
secrétaire général de notre ami nous a
rejoint sur ce plateau bonjour au tam
journée sans faire pour que cela on
vient d'entendre pour les préconisations
du sénat mais le sénat frappe aussi un
grand coup on entendu en demandant des
poursuites pour parjure pour alexandre
benalla et vincent kraz ancien salarié
de la république en marche c'est lui que
l'on voit aux côtés de l'ancien chargé
de mission lors des violences de la
contrescarpe talent et oui effectivement
delphine pour les rapporteurs et pour le
président de la commission denquête il
est très clair que l'ancien chargé de
mission de l'elysée a menti sur les
raisons pour lesquelles il a obtenu un
permis de port d'armes
alexandre benalla a déclaré que ce
permis lui avait été délivrée pour des
raisons de sécurité personnelle et bien
tous les autres témoignages montrent que
ce permis lui a été délivré au titre de
ses missions à l'elysée il a été
notamment été contredit dans ses propos
par patrick strzoda le directeur de
cabinet des manuels macron regarder ces
extraits des auditions qui ont été
sélectionnés par quentin calmait
le port d'armes je vous le répète
n'étaient pas liées à la sécurité du
président de la république mais à ma
sécurité personnelle j'ai considéré là
aussi dans ma responsabilité de
directeur de cabinet en charge de la
sécurité de chef de l'état qu'il pouvait
être utile dans ces circonstances de
déplacements privés qu'il y ait dans
l'entourage du président république
une personne qui est un port d'armes
mais qui est habilité à la voir qu'il a
la formation pour la voir et qu'il a eue
dans le cadre d'une instruction
parfaitement régulière qui pose problème
dans les déclarations oui puisque les
sénateurs ont relevé pas moins de sept
pages de faux témoignages et je cite de
retenue significatif d'information et de
très nombreuses interventions
d'alexandre benalla sont concernés
écoutez le également sur la question des
passeports diplomatiques là encore son
témoignage est contredit par celui de
patrick strzoda la délivrance de
passeports diplomatiques et automatique
différent cependant de passeports
diplomatiques oui et est automatique
pour l'ensemble des personnels qui
peuvent être amenés à se déplacer avec
le président de la république en ce
qu'ils ont été rendus ils sont au bureau
que j'occupais à l'elysée donc je pense
que l'elysée a dû s'en occuper
l'inventaire du bureau qui a été
effectuée le 2 août confirme que les
passeports n'y était pas ni les mesures
qui ont été prises et que je viens de
vous détailler et pour lesquels il
existe des notes de service des
courriers qui sont à votre disposition
le permettent d'affirmer que les
passeports n'étaient pas à l'elysée le
19 septembre lorsque j'étais présent
devant vous sous serment et que j'ai
répondu à l'ensemble des questions qui
m'ont été posées
je vous ai dit ils doivent être dans mon
bureau à l'elysée et ils ont dû les
restituer suisse may phrasé est complète
je vous réaffirme solennellement sous
serment encore une fois que le 19
septembre mais passeport était à
l'elysée là encore des extraits qui ont
été sélectionnés par quentin calme est
donc le 19 septembre benalla déclare que
les passeports sont restés à l'elysée et
lors de sa deuxième audition le 21
janvier il dit les avoir restitué dans
le courant de l'été avant d'ailleurs
qu'il y soit rendue par un collaborateur
du président de la république
l'ensemble les deux déclarations seront
fermement démenties par les mots de
patrick strzoda et pour les sénateurs il
est clair qu alexandre benalla a
délibérément cherché à tromper
ce sont là leurs mots il a cherché à
tromper lors de la première audition
avoir de chercher à arranger la vérité
pour dissimuler son premier mensonge je
disais ta main les sénateurs vis
également vincent kra lancé l'ancien
salarié de la république en marche que
l'on voyait au côté d'alexandre benalla
le 1er mai sur ces violences se place de
la contrescarpe à paris
oui et vincent kraz est notamment visé à
propos de ses déclarations sur les
contrats russe et la société velours
vincent crasse dit n'avoir rien à voir
avec cette société de protection écoutez
comment ça se fait qu'il ya velours
clause protection et après franz klaus
protection alors jeune il a encore un
raja je n'ai choisi ni le nom du premier
ni le nom du deuxième puisque je n'ai
rien à voir avec ces deux sociétés
quant au fait que l'os ou s'il avait à
voir
oui mais c'est pas moi je ne suis pas
velours des propos qui depuis ont été
contredits par le président de la
société et velours qui a expliqué
l'implication de vincent kra z alexandre
benalla dans la conclusion de contrats
et également les révélations de
mediapart autour d'un contrat de
sécurité privée conclut pour le compte
de l'oligarque russe iskander makhmoudov
je rappelle que c'est faux témoignages
sont passibles de cinq ans de prison et
de 75000 euros d'amendé
merci beaucoup au tas mais on vous
retrouve tout au long de cette édition
spéciale et ce rapport du sénat sur
enfants après sept mois de tensions
entre la haute assemblée l'exécutif qui
à plusieurs reprises à critiquer le
travail des sénateurs pointant je cite
un risque de non respect de la
séparation des pouvoirs fabien becker en
toile de fond de la sphère benalla
l'exécutif a engagé un bras de fer avec
le sénat
pour l'elysée les travaux de la
commission denquête ont une visée
politique est une cible
emmanuel macron il est devant personne
n'est dupe de ce qui se passe de ce qui
s'est passé cet été de
l'instrumentalisation de ce qui est tout
de même une dérive au départ personnel
pour la majorité présidentielle
l'opposition et en particulier la droite
sénatoriale serait donc engagée dans une
chasse aux sorcières pour affaiblir le
président de la république et
porteraient surtout atteinte à la
séparation des pouvoirs
je pense que ça pose un précédent c'est
pas à l'assemblée ni au sénat de rendre
la justice sur quelques affaires que ce
soit sinon ça veut dire quoi c'est à
dire qu'on va créer des commissions
d'enquêté systématiquement pour une
double au nez des enquêtes en cours
les sénateurs n'enquête pas sur les
faits reprochés alexandre benalla le 1er
mai dernier
mais sur une chaîne de
dysfonctionnements au sein de l'appareil
d'état
il affirme donc jouer le rôle de
surveillance de l'exécutif qui incombent
au parlement nous n'avons pas attachés à
ces tentatives de créer la polémique ou
de pression la moindre importance
senna est libre et indépendant il a fait
son travail avec sérénité avec humilité
aussi et le porte parole du gouvernement
n'attend pas d'avoir eu le rapport entre
les mains pour riposter
le lycée aura l'occasion d'apporter des
réponses factuelles sur manifestement
beaucoup de contre vérités qui se trouve
présente dans le rapport il appartiendra
désormais à la justice de donner une
suite aux éléments avancés par la
commission denquête salle des
conférences du sénat le président du
groupe allait à la haute assemblée les
sénateurs l ère de la vendée bruno
retailleau
oui bruno retailleau votre réaction aux
propos de benjamin griveaux qui pointe à
des contre-vérités dans le rapport de la
commission denquête qu'il le démontre
depuis le début monsieur griveaux et et
d'autres auraient souhaité que nous ne
nions pas justement cette enquête là je
voudrais rappeler que s'il y avait eu
simplement le l'assemblée nationale
l'enquète ce serait close en quelques
semaines bien et bien heureusement qu'il
ya eu le sénat heureusement qu'en france
il ya des contre-pouvoirs et je pense
que ça c'est important pour la
démocratie
maintenant si monsieur griveaux dit
il ya des contre vérités qu'il le montre
qu'il le démontre ce que savent les
français désormais c'est que au coeur de
l'elysée on a eu un individu qui aavait
d'un certain nombre de relations avec
des oligarques russes
voilà pour des gros contrats pour quelle
contrepartie je pose la question
ce que l'on sait aussi désormais c'est
que cet individu utilisaient des
documents en tout cas des passeports
diplomatiques pour rencontrer des chefs
d'état est ce que tout cela est normal
bien sûr que non donc notre travail à
nous c'est la manifestation de la vérité
c'est de faire en sorte qu' il ya des
recommandations qu'ils soient faites
pour que la sécurité au plus haut niveau
de l'état soit mieux assurée est pas
assurée par des gens qu'ils sont ni
policier ni gendarme justement dans
cette affaire est ce que vous pensez que
c'est la sphère d'un individu au dans
l'individu ou c'est tout un système qui
a dysfonctionné le risque évidemment
c'est que l'on fasse payer comme
d'habitude les lampistes bien si
monsieur benalla était au coeur de la
sécurité du président de république
c'est bien parce qu'ils avaient été
recrutés
nous ce que l'on souhaite éviter à
l'avenir c'est que de telles erreurs
puissent se reproduire
j'aurais vous faire réagir à une
déclaration accueillie en faire que
vient de faire à l'instant la garde des
sceaux nicole belloubet qui estime que
dans cette commission d'enquêté ce
rapport on n'est pas tout à fait dans le
respect de la séparation des pouvoirs
votre réaction ma réaction c'est que on
voit bien que l'elysée organise la
montée en puissance d'un certain nombre
de personnalités qui sont liées à
monsieur macro on voit deux ministres on
voit aussi monologue à l'assemblée
nationale qui préside le groupe en
marche mais ça ne nous fait pas cillé du
tout vous savez nous on a des règles
nous avons fait condamné il ya quelques
mois
justement par parjure à un professeur de
médecine dans les mêmes conditions alors
il n'y a pas deux poids deux mesures
nous avons des règles et nous essayons
de les observer
c'est tout de façon très rigoureuse mais
je pense qu'il faut des contre-pouvoirs
en france alors ensuite qu'on nous
démontre s'il ya vraiment des
contrevérités mais très franchement les
français ont pu observer le sérieux de
la commission des lois des rapporteurs
et du président philippe bas et
justement sur cette question du parjure
le rapport pointe la rétention de la
vérité parce trois hauts responsables de
l'elysée
alexis kohler patrick strzoda et lionel
lavergne et ce qu'il faut être sévère
avec eux c'est à la justice de le dire
maintenant vous m'indiquer que madame
belloubet et poser des questions avaient
des doutes mais madame et goudé est
aussi la mise de la justice
elle devrait observer que la justice a
eu maille à partir ces j'ose dire avec
monsieur b lada il ya une rétention
provisoire et on a appris en début
d'après midi qu'il y avait sans doute d
entrave à la manifestation de la vérité
donc je pense que il faut que les uns et
les autres puissent se calmer il faut
être serein
moi je pense qu'il faut qu'on améliore
le fonctionnement d'un certain nombre de
points qui touchent non pas la sécurité
privée d'un homme parce que la sécurité
des mails macron c'est la sécurité
nationale et les choix qui sont faits ne
sont pas des choix privé ce sont des
choix publics
c'est la raison pour laquelle il ya un
contrôle du parlement c'est tout c'est
la constitution c'est la règle
personne ne peut si j'ose dire y
échapper il faut se calmer à appliquer
les règles tout simplement voilà je ne
vois pas pourquoi on aurait fait
condamner un professeur de médecine
parce qu'il aurait menti sous serment et
que d'autres parce qu'ils sont puissants
ou parce qu'ils sont bien placés ne
mériterait pas le même traitement
on est totalement étranger à ce genre de
considérations très bien merci bruno
retailleau d'avoir répondu à mes
questions
merci beaucoup alexandre pour cette
réaction en direct hamon a parlé en des
cas d'alexandre benalla et de vincent
crabbe le sait la pointe aussi et bruno
retailleau vient de l'évoquer la
possible alors je suis de réponse ion
d'informations de la part de trois
hautes personnalités ou sans les viser
secrétaire général alexis colère le
directeur de cabinet patrick strzoda
mais aussi le shaq du gspr c'est le
groupement de sécurité de la présidence
de la république
c'est le général lionel lavergne qui est
visé mais alors le terme exact employés
dans le rapport ces rétentions
significatif d'une part de la vérité
en clair les sénateurs ont voulu une
formation diplomatique un euphémisme
pour parler des cas de ces hauts
fonctionnaires de l'elysée ils n'ont pas
voulu les mettre dans exactement la même
case qu'alexandre benalla et vincent
kraz mais en fait c'est une manière de
dire qu'ils ont empêché la vérité de se
faire très clairement dans leur rapport
ils disent que patrick strzoda alexis
colère et que le général lionel lavergne
ont monté un je vous le livre c'est
écrit noir sur blanc
la commission a pu établir
plusieurs personnes entendues ont menti
sur le périmètre exact des missions qui
a été confiée à alexandre benalla il
cite ensuite ces trois hauts
fonctionnaires écouter patrick strzoda
le 25 juillet 2018
je dois en cet instant vous peut-être si
vous permettez vous dire quelles étaient
les missions qui était confiée à
monsieur benalla ses missions d'ailleurs
qui font l'objet d'une note de service
que vous pouvez nous produire oui oui
absolument
monsieur benalla avant avant les
incidents du 1er mai avec trois missions
la première il participait sous
l'autorité du chef de cabinet à la
préparation et à l'organisation des
déplacements publics du chef de l'état
j'y reviendrai dans quelques instants sa
deuxième mission il était chargé
d'organiser les déplacements privés du
chef de l'état et troisième mission
il avait en charge le la gestion du
programme d'accueil des invités du
président de la république pour le
défilé du 14 juillet vous l'entendez
patrick strzoda delphine ne parle pas de
missions de sécurité
c'est la même chose même élément de
langage on peut dire thème du côtés
d'alexis colère alexis colère le
secrétaire général de l'elysée qui va
même plus loin on va l'écouter non je
sais pas une mission de coordination de
sécurité
c'est une mission de coordination de
tous qui doit tout ce qui contribue à au
cas d'espèce l'organisation d'un
déplacement du président d'un public
alexis colère ni même donc alexandre
benalla et eu une quelconque mission de
sécurité
alors ces témoignages sont contredits
par de nombreux éléments entame on va
également d'abord écouter également le
général lionel lavergne le chef du
gesppe air qui lui aussi est intervenu
sur l'émission d'alexandre reynal à
delphine
ces missions étaient triples la plus
importante mission c'était la
participation à l'organisation des
déplacements officiels du président de
la république sous l'autorité du chef de
cabinet à ce titre il assuré la
coordination des services qui concourt à
l'organisation du déplacement
conformément au programme qui sont
arrêtés par le chef de cabinet le
deuxième volet de sa mission de ses
prérogatives
c'était l'organisation des déplacements
non-officiel du président de la
république
troisième volet qui ne rendent pas qui
est pas en lien direct avec les missions
du j'espère c'était la gestion des
invitations pour le 14 juillet je
précise que à l'époque
eh bien il était encore colonel lionel
lavergne que depuis il a été promu
général quelques jours après cette
audition et qu'il est en charge de la
sécurité du président de la république
vous l'avez entendu il donne beaucoup de
détails alexandre benalla organise les
déplacements officiels
il coordonne les services qui organise
ses déplacements il s'occupe des
déplacements non officielle des manuels
macro il gère les invitations
ouais et on voit ce que c'est tous ces
témoignages sont contre lui à présent à
cannes oui effectivement ils sont
contredits par la note de service que
les sénateurs ont réussi à obtenir cette
note qui décrit l'organisation de la
chefferie de cabinet du président de la
république daté du 5 juillet 2017
les sénateurs après plusieurs relances
l'ont obtenu le 10 octobre 2018 et on y
lit bien qu alexandre bédat à cinq
missions et que la première d'entre
elles c'est d'assurer la coordination
des services de sécurité de la
présidence de la république
merci beaucoup tam pour toutes ces
précisions et on retrouvera un peu plus
tard dans de cette émission spéciale on
continue à d'ailleurs vers action
politique avec vous et alexandre
pouchard puisque vous êtes avec pierre
laurent a sénateurs comme une salle de
paris et oui justement delphine on va
réagir avec pierre laurent sur ces trois
hauts responsables de l'elysée qui
pourrait être poursuivi pour faux
témoignage en tout cas pour rétention
d'une partie la vérité
lors de leur audition qu'en pensez vous
je crois que le sénat a fait
correctement son
son travail donc a effectivement deux
choses dans le rapport d une demande de
poursuites pour faux témoignages
concernant alexandre benalla et en même
temps effectivement des demandes que la
justice éclaircisse si dans les
témoignages de haut responsable de
l'elysée il n'y a pas eu des omissions
ou des approximations qui auraient été
préjudiciables à la manifestation de la
vérité
donc toutes ces questions sont posées
avec beaucoup de précision dans le
rapport de la commission d enquête
sénatoriale qui demande tout
naturellement maintenant à la justice de
prendre le relais qui demande que des
poursuites soient instruites pour
pouvoir justement éclaircir
définitivement tous les faits finalement
cette affaire ce sont tous les
dysfonctionnements d'un système qui sont
mis en lumière oui absolument on voit
bien qu'il s'agit pas seulement de la
situation de tel ou tel homme il s'agit
du fait que à l'intérieur du système de
l'état au plus haut niveau de l'état
il ya eu des dysfonctionnements graves
pour la démocratie et le cdh a je crois
a fait une oeuvre utile en allant au
bout du travail de la commission
alors qu'à l'assemblée on sait que la
commission a été très vite stoppée par
la majorité aux marches ici nous avons
été au bout du travail et je le répète
il est parfaitement légitime maintenant
que soit engagé des poursuites qui sont
demandées dans le sénat parce qu'il ya
eu faux témoignage et donc c'est c'est
la règle quand il y as faux témoignage
il doit y avoir poursuite jeu devant une
commission d enquête
il doit y avoir poursuites judiciaires
alors apparemment cela publication de ce
rapport fait monter un peu la tension
entre l'exécutif et le sénat benjamin
griveaux parle de contre vérités nicole
belloubet parle d'un non respect de la
séparation des pouvoirs
quelle est votre réaction je crois que
le gouvernement n'a pas fait beaucoup
preuve de prudence et le moins qu'on
puisse dire dans cette affaire devrait
cette fois ci être un peu plus prudent
que ça parce que déjà au début de la
faire ils nous ont expliqué qu'ils
avaient rien du tout et puis on s'est
aperçu très vite qu'il y avait des faits
graves
donc moi j'inviterai
le gouvernement à la prudence et si ces
déclarations présager du fait que
chercherait à entraver la mise en oeuvre
des poursuites qui sont aujourd'hui qui
doivent être engagés légitimement pour
faire totalement la clarté là ce serait
encore plus grave encore donc je crois
que le gouvernement devrait faire
attention parce que le rapport est d'une
précision chirurgicale établi les faits
clairement et donc il faut en tenir
compte
très bien merci pierre laurent d'avoir
ainsi à mes questions merci beaucoup
alexandre pour cette nouvelle réaction
va continuer d' analyser les
conséquences de la publication de ce
rapport sénatorial sur la sphère benalla
avec mes invités qui m'ont rejoint sur
ce plateau j'ai le plaisir d'accueillir
muriel jourda
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
sénatrice et l'air ni mort bien qu
rapporteur de cette commission d'
enquête parlementaire jean luc fichet
est également avec mon bon soir vous
êtes un sénateur socialiste du finistère
philippe bonnecarrère est également sur
ce plateau bonsoir sénateurs centristes
du tarn et puis pour nous éclairer sur
cette affaire et benallal jean garrigues
êtes historien professeur à l'université
d'orléans et à sciences po
merci à d'être sur ce plateau meriem
jourda après sept mois de travaux ce
rapport tant attendu enfants était
présenté ce matin à la presse
un verdict implacable sévère pour
l'elysée écoutez j'ai le sentiment qu
effectivement l'elysée l'a trouvée
sévère nous nous sommes contentés d'être
assez factuel et d'analysé à la fois les
auditions les documents qui nous avaient
été adressées et qui effectivement ou
font ressortir un certain nombre de
dysfonctionnements que nous ne pouvions
pas passer sous silence
il ya une volonté politique un une sorte
de travail politique qui a été fait avec
ce rapport sénatorial on voit jean luc
fichet les critiques nombreuses de la
part soit des membres du parti
présidentiel soit benjamin griveaux ans
qui justement a parlé de contrevérités à
l'essai du conseil des ministres ce
matin on se pose la question de savoir
si ils prennent la mesure du problème
qui est posé puisque au delà de la
sphère benalla ce que l'on constate
quand même est-ce que le rapport met
bien en évidence
c'est l'ensemble des dysfonctionnements
qui tourne autour de la présidence de la
république est bien évidemment que à
chaque étape les choses on dit mais non
c'est une tempête dans un verre d'eau
c'est pas grave qui
chercher puis tout d'un coup il ya un
rapport qui la suite d'un travail
conséquent qui a été fait par des
sénateurs et qui met en évidence des
dysfonctionnements qui les nomme et qui
dit voilà maintenant on faire des
propositions pour que cela ne se
reproduise plus a bien sûr que
l'appartement où la chose est dite et
les fêtes bat ça pose des problèmes et
ça gêne ceux qui n'y croyaient pas
jusqu'à maintenant le sénat est dans son
rôle philippe bonnecarrère avec cette
mission le contrôle parlementaire
je crois que oui il faut jamais reproché
au sénat de vouloir aller plus loin dans
le travail est aussi d'aller plus loin
en termes de transparence je crois aussi
que le sénat qui a un mode électoral qui
lui est propre
en tout cas qui est indépendant de
l'élection présidentielle doit jouer son
rôle de contre-pouvoir peut être un peu
une nuance par rapport à une forme de
tension
à la première lecture de ce rapport il
ya effectivement des constatations de
dysfonctionnements mais il ya aussi
treize propositions qui me semble-t-il
sont pondérées raisonnable et peuvent
intéresser l'exécutif
une fois que il aura souhaitait en
prendre une lecture plus apaisé qu'est
ce que le rapport de nature à apaiser
les relations entre la haute assemblée
l'exécutif au contraire est-ce que ça
mais pas sûr que ça aboutisse un
apaisement des relations mais sera
abouti au moins à deux choses d'une part
à faire reconnaître par le grand public
ce qu'est le rôle du sénat ce qu'est un
contre-pouvoir législatif est à mes yeux
d'amoureux du système parlementaire
c'est quelque chose de très important et
je pense que cette commission
sénatoriale a joué ce rôle de manière
exemplaire avec à la fois la précision
et la retenue qui s'imposait en laissant
d'un côté tout ce qui concernait les
investigations judiciaires et en se
polarisant sur les questions de
fonctionnement du système politique
et la deuxième chose c'est ce sont
précisément ces préconisations moi en
tant qu observateur de la vie politique
il ya très longtemps que que je pointe
ces dysfonctionnements la toute
puissance du système présidentiel de la
présidence dans le système de cinquième
république
on est véritablement là
la preuve tangible je veux dire que il y
à une nécessité de réguler le
recrutement des collaborateurs de
l'elysée de de faire d'enquêté sur l'or
donc je vous dire que ces préconisations
sont très importantes parce qu'au fond
c'est ce qui ce qui va ressortir de ceux
de c2c enquête est tout l'enjeu on voit
bien le sénat ce n'était bien donc pas
empiéter sur le travail de la justice a
été d'ailleurs rappelé en ce matin par
fini bas le président la commission
desbois président de cette commission
denquête je propose de l'écouter tout de
suite il ya la part de l'autorité
judiciaire
il y à la part de l' enquête
parlementaire elles sont complémentaires
et elles vont dans la même direction
c'est très important de les dire
nous avons confiance dans les
institutions de la république le
parlement auquel nous appartenons bien
sûr la présidence de la république
l'autorité judiciaire le gouvernement et
nous tenons à ce que cette confiance
soit confortée par les propositions que
nous faisons qui sont des propositions
constructives destinées à éviter qu'à
l'avenir on puisse se retrouver dans ce
genre de situation rien le journa des
propositions constructives qui souligne
malgré tout c'est un premier constat que
la sécurité du président de la
république a été particulièrement
affectée pendant la première année elle
de son quinquennat en cause la présence
d'alexandre benalla à ses côtés oui tout
à fait c'est un constat que nous avons
pu faire qui est que malgré toutes les
dénégations qui ont été apportées
monsieur benalla avait deux fêtes de
fait un rôle de garde du corps est en
tout cas si nice est dans la sécurité du
président alors qu'on sait que cette
sécurité traditionnellement et bien elle
est exercée souhaite par des militaires
souhaitent par les officiers de sécurité
civile
mais en tout cas par des professionnels
qui sont formés et introduire alexandre
bédat là au milieu de ce système n'a pu
que le faire dysfonctionné donc ça
c'était une une vraie difficulté qu'il
fallait relever il fallait réaffirmer
que conformément à ce qui s'est toujours
passé et bien ce devait être des
professionnels formés entraînés pour ce
faire qui devait assurer la sécurité du
président de la république
enfin pu avoir des conséquences graves à
la présence de ce collaborateur
officieux de ses
qui voulait peut-être réorganiser la
sécurité en mode privé jean-luc affiche
et c'est ce qu'on a cru comprendre
effectivement s'il y avait un projet de
réorganisation auprès du président de la
république d'un système de sécurité
privée et donc on peut s'inquiéter
effectivement de cette mesure là alors
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que derrière
ça aussi il ya quand même ce cheminement
de alexandre bédat l'art qui est
brigadier de gendarmerie et qui devient
comme par miracle lieutenant colonel de
gendarmerie de l'opération réservistes
dans l'opérationnel ce qui est quand
même absolument fantastique puisque ce
sont des années des années de formation
pour laquelle ces types de compétences
avec ça car pour quelqu'un qui a 27 ans
et qui tout d'un coup est érigée au
sommet un petit peu des grades de
l'agent abri et sans formation puisque
la formation qu'il a reçue par ce qui
nous a présenté lors des auditions est
vraiment minimum
donc effectivement c'est inquiétant
place excessive au sein de l'elysée
selon vous au feeling bonnecarrère
alexandre bénin probablement je ne suis
pas forcément passionnés madame par la
vie et les oeuvres de monsieur benalla
ce qui est plus important c'est l'aspect
général nous sommes un pays qui en
régime très présidentiel appartement où
notre régime est très présidentiel il
faut s'assurer que son fonctionnement
soit bien sûr optimum hélas ce dossier a
été le révélateur à la fois du fait
qu'un collaborateur avait très
clairement trompé la confiance du
président de la république mais aussi
qu'il y avait des améliorations à
apporter
proposer des améliorations ne paraît pas
une atteint atteinte une atteinte à
l'équilibré aux institutions c'est pour
ça que je pense qu'on peut aussi avoir
une vision de ce rapport apaisé comme je
l'indiquais ya quelques secondes
jean garrigues mais ça n'interdit parle
d'une incompréhensible indulgence dont a
pu bénéficier alexandre bénin
oui on le sait bien sans langue de bois
la campagne des manuels macron s'est
fait sur un ensemble d'une dizaine de
personnes très resserré alexandre
benalla a donné des gages de ses
capacités de son expertise en matière de
sécurité il a été une sorte d'homme de
confiance de manuel macron on voit très
bien ce qui s'est passé il a été
propulsé dans une fonction pour laquelle
il n'était pas taillé parce que on peut
dire qu'il ya aussi un peu pété les
plombs comme comme l'aurait fait
beaucoup de jeunes de son âge en se
voyant investi 2,7 tout puissant et
c'est ça qui pose problème c'est que la
fonction présidentielle ce qu'est le
rôle du président dans notre
constitution dans nos institutions fait
qu' une sorte d'aura de toute puissance
qui lui a permis d'obtenir le passe
droit d'aller faire du service d'ordre
place de la contrescarpe d'avoir des
passeports diplomatiques etc etc rade de
garder un téléphone théorème tout ça
participe d'une révérence excessive
envers un pouvoir qui n'est pas assez
codifié et régulé donc si on peut le
codifier le réguler dans la mesure où
c'est ça reste le pouvoir majeur dans
nos institutions
je pense qu'il faudrait y réfléchir
aussi mais en tout cas dans la mesure où
on a là quelqu'un un instrument de toute
puissance avec la fonction
présidentielle
alors il faut la codifier la réguler il
est bien que les contre-pouvoirs
notamment contre pouvoirs législatifs
s'exprime donc tout ça me paraît sain et
j'ajouterais quelque chose on est dans
une période très de crise majeure de la
démocratie représentative de
contestation de la démocratie
représentative
quel meilleur exemple pour légitimer
cette démocratie que de voir un sénat
qui fait son travail de contre-pouvoir
que de proposer une régulation de ceux
des excès de la présidence
moi ça me paraît très très positif il
n'ya eu une dérive personnelle c'est ce
qu'on a voulu nous faire croire un temps
et rien de jourda finalement cet
argumentaire ne tient pas selon vous il
ya probablement une dérive personnelle
parce que nous parlons de comportement
personnel et j'adhère totalement à
l'analyse qui vient d'être faite sur le
fait que le pouvoir élyséen a pu en
quelques sortes monté à la tête de
monsieur bénin
mais ces dérives peuvent exister partout
il faut que le système puisse les
rennais c'est ça la difficulté qu'il y
ait une dérive peut arriver mais là nous
n'avons pas vu de frein à tous ces
comportements personnels de monsieur
benalla bien au contraire je crois qu'on
lit à encourager parce que finalement
quoiqu'il ait demandé il l'a obtenu y
compris lorsqu on pouvait se poser des
questions sur la nécessité des moyens
qui le demandaient donc dérive
personnelle certes mais qui n'a pas été
freinée par un système de régulation tel
qu'il vient d'être décrit qui permettait
d'encadrer les collaborateurs du
président de la république nous en clair
par là lui et bien une sorte de
surpuissance je propose d'écouter le co
rapporteur socialiste de cette
commission enquête la liberté les
pouvoirs excessifs laisser un chargé de
mission dans un domaine aussi sensible
que la sécurité du chef de l'état
témoigne aux yeux de notre commission de
l'imprudence de la présidence de la
république dans l'encadrement d'un
individu qui avait pourtant fait preuve
par le passé de comportement
professionnel inapproprié vous lirez le
rapport la commission a ainsi découvert
qu alexandre benalla avait été licencié
de son poste de chauffeur personnel de
monsieur arnaud montebourg alors
ministre du redressement productif en
raison de son manque de jeu site
discrétion responsabilité et
transparence notamment parce qu'il
s'était prévalu du soutien du ministre
pour une demande déjà de permis de port
d'armes
jean luc fichet qu'est ce que ça vous
inspire ya un problème s'il devait me
manque d'effectivité de la sanction à
l'encontre je pense que vient de dire le
rapporteur sur et est très important
c'est que monsieur benhadda est un
modèle est embauché comme ç'avait de
sécurité dans une campagne électorale il
fait bien son travail
ma foi il ya quand même cette histoire
avec que chez montebourg où on met fin à
ses fonctions par manque de discrétion
mais pour un comportement qui n'est pas
adaptée à la situation
voilà donc autant qu'à de petits signes
d' alerte qui font que le personnage
peut être très bon dans une mission bien
encadrés etc
je pense que dans cette affaire monsieur
benalla était d'une telle disponibilité
d'une telle bonne volonté que ça
effacer son incompétence et que tout
d'un coup il s'est rendu indispensable
et donc il a progressé naturellement
dans une sorte de hiérarchie parallèle
jusqu'à devenir le directeur adjoint de
la chefferie auprès du président de la
république ce qui est absolument
phénoménale et quelqu'un qui à 27 ans
qui vit un parcours pareil on peut
comprendre que à un moment donné ça
explose dans sa tête mais quel besoin
avait-il malgré tout et c'est bien là
aux mesures le décalage de prendre tout
d'un coup une matraque pour aller casser
du manifestant alors que c'est
absolument dehors de tout et c'est
vraiment a considéré que le comportement
tu avais un problème aussi de manquement
aux règles déontologiques
philippe bonnecarrère qu'est ce qu'on
fait maintenant justement pour garantir
et bien la sécurité du président de la
république faut plus de transparence
aussi c'est ce qui vous préconisées dans
le rapport
alors c'est probablement un des espoirs
pour le coup les plus désagréables du
dossier cette espèce déontologique alors
il y a des règles avec des déclarations
d'intérêt déclaration de patrimoine et
surtout une des déclarations d intérêt
que l'on peut avoir et il y à des
dysfonctionnements dans dossier pénal
c'est très clair mais il y a aussi une
part sombre avec ces deux contrats
passés avec les oligarques russes et ça
je crois que pour tous mes collègues
c'est vraiment une ligne une ligne rouge
la russie n'est pas un pouvoir neutre
les oligarques n'agissent pas de leur
propre chef
et quant à travers des oligarques un
pays nous ici vous me permettez cette
expression un peu triviale à travers des
montants importants des personnes qui
sont dans le dispositif de sécurité
là cela donne effectivement caractère
risqué et je crois que le sénat est
effectivement dans son rôle pour que nos
concitoyens confiance dans l'institution
aller jusqu'au bout de ses recherches et
de ses analyses ses contrats jean
garrigues
ça prouve qu'il ya peut-être eu un
enrichissement personnel de la part
d'alexandre benalla qui avait accès à
bien des documents secret défense ça
porte atteinte aux intérêts de la
présidence de la république de la france
ça pourrait en tout cas il ya suspicion
ce qui est sûr c'est que d'après les
enregistrements de médiapart
il ya eu participation à un contrat avec
vincent kraz et un lien quelconque
peut-être un lien assez fort avec le
lydia recrues ce mag nov des
spécialistes de la question des
questions de sécurité mon fils que a
priori ce bac blood of en question n'est
pas si proche de vladimir poutine qu'on
pourrait le croire
ce qui fait que au fond le risque de
conflit pour la sécurité de l'état est
peut-être moins importants qu'on peut
mais pour l'instant on n'en sait rien je
vais la mafia et le parquet à la cena
financier vous verrez voilà ce qui est
important c'est la suspicion de conflit
d'intérêts de toute manière il ya il ya
un sujet on sait bien aussi que monsieur
bénard a fait beaucoup de séjour avec
mexico sans passeport diplomatique au
cameroun au tchad etc
ça pose quand même des questions et le
fait d'avoir ça c'était après mes os à
l'elysée participez à conclusion de
contrats même c'était contrat de
sécurité avec le lui dire que makhmoudov
évidemment ça pose forcément des
problèmes je rappelle en tant
qu'historien que ce type de personnage
ce type d'abus de pouvoir ont déjà
existé dans l'entourage élyséen
et si on se souvient ne serait-ce que de
la sphère des écoutes téléphoniques de
l'élysée on avait là une affaire qui
était au moins aussi grave est aussi
important muriel jourda c'est contre un
russe c'est la présidence de la
république
le péché finalement par imprudence selon
vous il faut en tout cas trouvé un
système y compris assorties de sanctions
pénales pour que les obligations
déontologiques soit véritablement
respecter
monsieur là il avait l'obligation de
déclarer ses activités à une commission
de déontologie
il ne l'a pas fait et on ne lui a pas
demandé donc effectivement il ya une
responsabilité qui est réciproque même
si on patente que monsieur ben alpha
spontanément parce que cela était digne
les contrats russe cette proximité peut
être avec le pouvoir russe pose un
problème pour quelqu'un qui se trouve au
plus
près du président de la république et ça
ne doit pas exister ces suspicions ne
doivent pas exister même si elles ne
sont pas suivies d'effet ça n'est pas
possible que quelqu'un qui soit aussi
près du président de la république est
aussi proche de sa sécurité et des
contacts directs ou indirects avec une
puissance étrangère
c'est la proposition numéro 6 1 prévoir
par la loi des sanctions pénales
justement en cas de manquement aux
obligations de déclaration un d'une
nouvelle activité à la commission
déontologie d'autant que c'est ce qu'on
impose aux parlementaires jean luc
fichet certains soldats et ont vu une
sorte de revanche de la part des
parlementaires
absolument pas je crois que c'est pas du
tout notre état d'esprit on n'est pas
dans les sables de revanche d'autant que
l'on traite d'un dossier qui n'est pas
du tout de même nature
nous sommes nous contraint à rendre
compte de nos situations et ce qui est
bien normal je crois qu'on a tous adhéré
au dispositif et ça nous convient
maintenant pour ce qui concerne les gens
qui travaillent proche des ministres
proches du président de la république
il semble effectivement pour le moins
que l'on doit veiller à ce qu'ils aient
des transparences et que l'on puisse
effectivement contrôlé leurs faits et
gestes puisque qu'on constate quand même
que monsieur benalla avait démarré ses
contrats dès le mois de mars
alors qu'à ce moment là il n'était
touché par aucune affaire il était
toujours actif auprès du présent d'un
public et pour autant il a une vie
parallèle il ya quand même des éléments
qui devraient permette d'identifier cela
assez rapidement ça n'a pas été le cas
et donc à elles ont prospéré et elles
ont continué à prospérer au delà du 1er
mai au delà du 15 mai au delà du 28
juillet et c'est cela qui est tout à
fait surprenant parce que on aurait pu
imaginer bien évidemment qu'après les
histoires du 1er mai des champions était
presqu'une ont d'ailleurs été appliquée
que partiellement on aurait pu imaginer
que cela cesse dire qu'à un moment donné
on arrête complètement des ans bras vous
êtes renvoyé vous n'existez plus dans le
champ de 2 auprès de la présence d'un
public ni à l'elysée ni en tant que
fonctionnaire et puis vous allez rendre
des comptes sur aux agissements auquel
cas la faire s'arrêter
naturellement je crois et puis le
rapport du sénat bureau était assez
motifs simples avec des préconisations
qui est chaud effectivement qu'il faut
quand même prendre des mesures pour
faire en sorte qu'il y ait plus de
clarté dans les modes de recrutement
et puis aussi que y ait cette confiance
importante qui soit restaurée vous avez
des services de rameurs et une police
qui eux ne sont pas défaillant qui ne
soit pas défaillant et qui nous ont dit
dès les premières auditions d'ailleurs
nous on subissait ce personnage nous
étions très très mal à l'aise parce
qu'ils étaient avec nous à traitable il
était irritable difficile et d'avions
cas nous exécuter il pose quand même
question des premières auditions de la
commission d enquête parlementaire de
mémoire les syndicats de police et ça
vous a marqué ce qu'ils vous ont dit
philippe bonnecarrère seulement sur le
personnage alexandre benallal est un
élément ce n'est peut-être pas le point
plus fort puisque cela n'a pas ensuite
été confirmée dans la suite des travaux
mais au-delà de cela
l'essentiel pour nos concitoyens dans la
tente la recherche de confiance qu'il ya
aujourd'hui au coeur de la société c'est
de savoir que dans le pays
lorsqu'il ya un problème très clairement
de faire benalla démontre un problème il
est possible d'aller rechercher les
vérités il est possible de faire son
travail en toute transparence et on est
dans un pays où les institutions
fonctionnent la démocratie
représentative a effectivement ses
faiblesses elle a promis un bain nette
renforcée par la démocratie dite
participative
mais nos concitoyens voient bien que le
fonctionnent que la séparation des
pouvoirs et la ya un président de la
république a une autorité politique
forte
mais il y a des formes de contre-pouvoir
ont des pouvoirs indépendants la justice
et le parlement est à cet égard ce matin
le sénat fait très clair assumer très
clairement son rôle dans les conclusions
qui ont été les siennes on attendait ce
rapport avec impatience on attendait
aussi est bien de savoir si les
sénateurs allaient saisir la justice
pour parjure ça a été non confirmée par
philippe baron l'écoutent comme l'
ordonnance de 1958 relative à l'exercice
de ses pouvoirs dans quête par le
parlement le prévoit j'ai donc décidé
conjointement avec les deux rapporteurs
et après avoir consulté ce matin la
commission des lois de demander au
président du sénat que le bureau
de notre assemblée c'est la procédure
délibère en vue de saisir le procureur
de la république de paris
des faux témoignages caractérisée de
monsieur benalla des contradictions
apparues entre les premières
déclarations de collaborateurs immédiats
du président de la république sur le
rôle de monsieur benalla en matière de
sécurité et les éléments et témoignages
recueillis par la suite tout en
soulignant d'ailleurs la qualité et la
précision de nombreuses informations qui
nous ont été apportées par les dix
collaborateurs sur d'autres points très
importants
nous souhaitons aussi que l'ensemble du
rapport soit lui même transmis au
procureur de la république afin qu'il
puisse apprécier l'existence éventuelle
d'autres faux témoignage susceptible
d'avoir été commis par des personnes
auditionnées
il appartient donc au bureau d'en
décider
jean garrigues parure peut-être pour 2
personnes voire cinq
c'est rare très rare
ça pose ça pose le problème fondamental
de ce sentiment d'impunité de du pouvoir
présidentiel ça c'est quelque chose de
récurrent et qui était un poison
finalement de de la lutte contre toutes
les formes d'abus de pouvoir non
seulement sous la vème et depuis que la
démocratie parlementaire existe on voit
très bien que le premier réflexe du
pouvoir exécutif du pouvoir présidentiel
dans cette affaire a été on ferme la
boutique et on ne dit rien on se
calfeutre dans notre toute puissance
présidentielle emmanuel macron c'est
très clair politiquement il aurait dû
tout de suite clarifier la situation
ses collaborateurs ont usé de demi
vérités
c'est une faute ils ont sanctionné là
aussi un peu ni figue mi raisin c'est
aussi une faute et tout ça vient de 7,7
culture présidentielle dont il est
surprenant de voir des hommes neufs
s'emparer et à user de cette manière
mais c'est c'est un poison je le répète
et dans la société qui est la nôtre
l'exigence d'horizontalité transparence
de contre-pouvoir qui est la nôtre ça ne
passe plus et ceux qui pouvaient encore
se faire il ya vingt ans parce que ça se
faisait il ya 20 ans aujourd'hui ça ne
ne peut plus fonctionner et il faudra
peut-être que il ya des sanctions
justement le le sénat dans son
raisonnement pour son serment devant une
commission d enquête parlementaire le
sénat saisie la justice est ensuite à la
justice de procéder
oui meriane jourda sur ce point vous
avez la certitude qu'il a donc eu
parjure pour ces deux personnes mais on
voit le sénat et bien qu'il pourrait
élargir cette demande de saisine de la
justice pour trois hauts fonctionnaires
de l'elysée il est vrai que nous avons
peut-être un peu plus de certitudes pour
monsieur bennama et pour monsieur kraz
s'agissant des contrats russe puisque on
a eu plusieurs éléments qui ont confirmé
qu' ils ont participé à la conclusion de
ces contrats alors même qu'il vous avait
affirmé l inverse au moment où il est et
à l'elysée nous avons aussi des doutes
assez force agissante des passeports
diplomatiques de monsieur b dallas est
le fait qu'il les ait laissés ou qui ne
les ai pas laissé en réalité il a fait
des déclarations qui sont incompatibles
entre elles qui ne sont pas compatibles
avec ce que nous a dit monsieur strzoda
et qui n'ont pas été démentis de façon
claire en tout cas sur des éléments
probants et ensuite bien sûr il y a
aussi d'autres éléments sur lesquels ils
viennent nous avons des membres de
l'elysée qui ont retenu une partie de la
vérité
une partie de la vérité qui nous était
essentielle à ce moment là nos
interrogations
et bien sûr nous ne pouvons pas le
passer sous silence et ça me paraît
essentiel vous attendait justement
maintenant de la justice sur le cadre de
ces trois personnes
nous attendons de l'air d'un gros
freinage oui numéro nous attendons du
bureau du sénat qu'il transmette au
parquet et qu'on fasse la clarté
ça n'a jamais été que le but de notre
commission denquête depuis le départ
c'est de faire la clarté sur des
fonctionnements qui nous paraissait
étrange c'est le rôle du sénat c'est le
rôle du parlement que de contrôler
effectivement l'exécutif c'est le rôle
constitutionnel et ce rôle il n'a de
sens que si effectivement lorsque l'on
vienne devant nous on ne nous ment pas
donc il me paraissait nécessaire et nous
étions entièrement d'accord avec le
président de la commission des lois jean
pierre sueur et moi puisque c'est une
prérogative du président de la
commission des lois pour que ces
incohérences ses invraisemblances et
probablement ses mensonges il ne reste
pas lettre morte
il en va de la crédibilité du sénat et
donc de la crédibilité
des contre-pouvoirs démocratiques jean
luc fichet on ne ment pas devant une
infinie membres devant une commission d
enquête parlementaire sous serment c'est
aussi le message qu'a voulu faire passer
la haute assemblée c'est un cas
extrêmement solennelle on ne ment pas en
général mais là tout particulièrement je
pense qu'effectivement le les personnes
qui sont entendus près de serment et
nouvellement attendons que la vérité
éclate dans le questionnement qui est le
nôtre et qui portent effectivement sur
un chemin qui est assez étroits puisque
nous tout ce qui concerne le judiciaire
ce n'est pas de notre responsabilité
on a bien fait attention à ne s'est pas
intéressé à savoir si les passeports
c'était avaient été utilisés quels
cadres etc
ce n'était pas ça c'est comment se
fait-il qu'à un moment donné ils soient
tributaires de quatre passeports et y
compris après même avant a été
sanctionné c'est ça notre questionnement
et on attend bien évidemment des
réponses claires des silences quand ça a
été le cas avec monsieur bénalia qui
nous est dit mais non je vous réponds
pas parce que l'instruction judiciaire
traite de cette question là et en quoi
je parle vous répondre ce qui a été
parfaitement respectée maintenant la
notion de mensonges on avait quand même
un peu identifiée on avait un peu perçu
elle s'est confirmée au fur et à mesure
du temps et là des conséquences est bas
et doivent être ce qu'elles doivent être
c'est à dire des sanctions d'où ce qu'on
espère de la décision du bureau du sénat
c'est effectivement de poursuivre les
bonnes carrières c'est pour ça qu'il
faut renforcer à la fois les pouvoirs de
contrôle du parlement mais aussi à
clarifier on disait l'obligation de
signalement d'un crime ou d'un délit
c'est en application l'article 40 années
passées au sol ont tout ceci relève de
la même chose de légitimité de nos
institutions
et quand mes collègues escrime leur
souhait de voir le bureau du sénat
transmettre au parquet de justificatifs
de ce que nous estimons avoir été des
mensonges devant notre commission c'est
à la fois la légitimité de travail du
sénat sur le dossier pénal a mais c'est
surtout important pour la pour la suite
il me paraît vraiment important pour nos
concitoyens qu'ils appréhendent que le
parlement à des outils de contrôle de
l'exécutif et des exécutifs dans la
durée ne sommes pas là sûr
ce x monsieur y ou le temps de telle
présidence et donc le fait que ces
commission denquête soit crédibilisée
par les conséquences qu'on en tire
y compris bien entendu la sanction
d'éventuels mensonge c'est un élément
qui me paraît positif pour la démocratie
donc aucune réserve sur le processus qui
a démarré ce matin on a commencé ce
débat jean garrigues en parlant des
rapports compliqués entre le sénat et
l'exécutif
ou est ce qu on pourrait avoir une
nouvelle crise institutionnelle ouverte
avec ces trois hauts fonctionnaires qui
se retrouve un peu dans l'oeil du
cyclone 9 ce soir ce serait une énorme
erreur de la part du pouvoir exécutif
que de transformer cette affaire d'un
bras de fer institutionnel parce qu'au
contraire je le répète tout le monde
peut gagner dans cette danse qui se
passe maintenant qu'il montre à quel
point je vous le répète ce
contre-pouvoir démocratique qu'est la
démocratie représentative sommes ici au
coeur d'une des deux assemblées
représentatives est important et peut
fonctionner justement pour assurer cette
thérapie ses tables amélioration du
système là c'est typiquement le cas on
peut améliorer notre système
démocratique sans forcément le renverser
le remettre en cause
le message est très très fort en réalité
dans un moment où on s'interroge
précisément sur ce fonctionnement sur la
légitimité de nos élus de gîtes imiter
de nos pouvoirs on s'aperçoit que ces
pouvoirs ils sont capables justement de
se transformer de s'améliorer et de
préconiser des améliorations moi je
pense que véritablement ce serait une
faute de la part de l'exécutif que deux
voilà de transformer ça en quelque chose
de polémique mais au contraire essayer
de réagir dans un sens positif
on vient vers ça bouge en garrigue merci
beaucoup muriel jourda remercie jean luc
fichet merci à vous les pubs en carrière
d'être venu sur ce plateau pour cette
édition spéciale et puis c'est une
coïncidence un hasard du calendrier à la
veille et bien de la présentation de ce
rapport on appris que alexandre benalla
et vincent kraz ont été placés hier soir
en détention provisoire avait des hommes
qui sont donc soupçonnés d'avoir violé
leur contrôle judiciaire vous avez en
effet interdiction de rentrer en contact
or les enregistrements révélés par
mediapart font état du contraire
explication quand un camion sur ces
images on peut voir alexandre benalla
arrivé libre au tribunal de paris
face au juge des libertés et de la
détention une audience s'est tenue dans
la soirée parquet et juge d'instruction
demande le placement en détention
provisoire de l'ancien chargé de mission
ainsi que de vincent kraz en sont
responsables de la sécurité dans marche
en cause la rencontre du 26 juillet dont
mediapart a diffusé les enregistrements
problème depuis le 22 juillet ils sont
tous les deux mis en examen et ont
interdiction de se voir il ya donc là
selon les magistrats une violation du
contrôle judiciaire hier soir le juge a
donc décidé de placer alexandre benalla
et vincent kraz en détention provisoire
une décision dénoncée par l'avocate de
l'ex chargé de mission oui je suis en
colère parce que alexandre dellal ai
rien à faire en prison
avec son bel à la n'a jamais été
condamné alexandre blain à 27 ans il un
bébé de 6 mois
il a fait deux gardes à vue il est venu
plusieurs fois chez les juges il est
toujours déféré aujourd'hui sur le
fondement d'extrait d' écoutes
téléphoniques coupées
produite par médiapart dont nous ne
connaissons pas l'auteur contre lesquels
le parquet a déposé une plainte en vain
car sert aujourd'hui pour une prétendue
concertation qui aurait lu il ya sept
mois tout cela est ridicule et je dis
qu'effectivement la justice sous
pression n'est pas une bonne justice et
je trouve ça profondément profondément
injuste un rebondissement judiciaire qui
intervient alors que de nouvelles
poursuites pourraient bientôt être
engagée dans le dossier les sénateurs
pourraient saisir le parquet sur les
soupçons de parjure contre alexandre
bénin du sénat était très attendue llr
sévère pour l'elysée dans un rapport de
près de 150 pages les sénateurs pointe
les défaillances de l'état
une présidence qui a péché par manque de
précaution notamment sur la question des
contrats russe 13 préconisations sont
ainsi formulé le détail à correia romano
de graves dysfonctionnements au plus
haut niveau de l'état c'est la
principale conclusion du rapport de la
commission d'enquêté sénatoriale sur la
sphère benalla pour les sénateurs la
sécurité du président de la république a
été affectée par la présence d'alexandre
benalla à ses côtés son manque
d'expérience couplée à la place
excessive qu'on lui a laissé prendre
tour d' emmanuel macron sont des erreurs
majeures la thèse de la faute de l'homme
isolé s'est effacé au profit du
dysfonctionnement d'une institution qui
a rendu possibles ces multiples
situations normales allant jusqu'à
affecté je crois que jean pierre sur
l'a10 très bien la sécurité du président
de la république il n'y a pas une seule
affaire pour les sénateurs mais
plusieurs affaires qui révèle tout des
dysfonctionnements la sphère des
passeports diplomatiques avec les graves
lacunes concernant leurs attributions et
surtout leur récupération
le cas des conflits d'intérêts avec le
contrat russe signé par alexandre le
dana alors qu'il est encore à l'elysée
en conséquence les préconisations de la
commission sont multiples
prévenir et sanctionner les conflits
d'intérêts parmi les collaborateurs des
cabinets pour qu'il ne soit dans l'amas
de personnes garantir le respect des
standards de sécurité les plus élevées
en ce qui concerne la protection du
président de la république et celle du
premier ministre
mieux encadrer la délivrance
l'utilisation le retrait des passeports
diplomatiques et de service
faire en sorte que les promotions dans
la réserve de la gendarmerie nationale
soit mieux réguler et plus généralement
veiller à ce que les collaborateurs des
autorités politiques n'interfère pas
avec le fonctionnement opérationnel des
administrations ceci est un point
évidemment très important parmi les
treize propositions de la commission
près de la moitié concerne le
fonctionnement de l'exécutif et
particulièrement le recrutement
l'encadrement et le contrôle des
collaborateurs de l'elysée
dessinateur souhaite aussi renforcer les
pouvoirs de contrôle du parlement sur
les services de la présidence de la
république
enfin les sénateurs de moins est ce que
la justice se penche sur les
déclarations mensongères d'alexandre
bénin ainsi que sur certaines omissions
les collaborateurs de l'elysée
auditionné
nous proposons au président du sénat et
au bureau du sénat de saisir le parquet
c'est clair premièrement pour monsieur
benalla écrase en parlant de faux
témoignages
deuxièmement nous demandons que pour les
collaborateurs de l'elysée précités le
parquet soit saisie au nom d'omissions
d'incohérences et de contradictions et
au nom du fait que les personnes
concernées ont retenu une part
significative de la vérité à la
commission
parmi ses collaborateurs figurent le
directeur de cabinet du président de la
république patrick strzoda ainsi qu
alexis colère le secrétaire général de l
affaire oui à marseille qu'est ce que
vous pensez des conclusions assez sévère
de ce rapport de la commission d'
enquête sur l' affaire pénale à l'écouté
sont pas de conclusions sévères sont les
conclusions tout simplement de six mois
de travail de beaucoup d'interrogations
d' analyse des documents des
déclarations des uns et des autres et
nous sommes arrivés à la conclusion
qu'il y avait beaucoup de choses à
améliorer parce qu'il y avait eu
beaucoup de dysfonctionnements
c'est tout un système finalement qui est
qui a qui n'a pas bien fonctionné ou
c'est l'histoire d'un homme isolé et
goûter je sais pas s'il faut appeler ça
un système en tout état de cause il
s'agit du chef de l'état de sa sécurité
du sommet de l'état et il se trouve
qu'il ya un homme un jeune homme
peut-être trop jeunes manquant
d'expérience peut-être livré à lui même
qui a commis 10 à qui n'aurait jamais dû
commettre d'abord à la contrescarpe un
certain 1er mai ce qui a lancé la faire
ce qui a déclenché cette affaire et puis
ensuite on découvre que ce jeune homme
il est auprès du chef de l'état qui
s'occupe de sa sécurité en fait même si
on lui reconnaît pas ce titre il est à
son épaule comme on dit
il est armé parfois il a des rapports
commerciaux avec un oligarque russe
on découvre tout un tas de choses avec
l'aide de la presse d'ailleurs
et donc il est normal qu'on en tire les
conclusions est ce que cette affaire
finalement elle révèle une certaine
pratique du pouvoir à l'elysée un
sentiment de toute puissance
je dirais que tout ça laisse une
impression un peu de ça veut dire
l'absence de professionnalisme quelque
part il faut que la sécurité du chef de
l'état soit assurée par des
professionnels sous couvert du ministère
de l'intérieur avec des gens dont on
sait qu'ils sont deux ils viennent dont
on peut être sûr et sont là tout le sens
des préconisations que formulent la
commission denquête et je crois que
c'est l'honneur du sénat que d'avoir
travailler dans ces conditions
et quand la mise de la justice nicole
belloubet estime que le sénat n'a pas
vraiment respecter la séparation des
pouvoirs
qu'est ce que cela vous inspire je
regrette que le garde des sceaux jaillir
s'exprime de cette façon là je pense que
le gouvernement il garde des sceaux
singulièrement aurait dû prendre acte
des conclusions et laisser à la justice
le soin de poursuivre l'action
du coup maintenant vous allez plaidé le
l'idée d'un renforcement du pouvoir du
contrôle du parlement notamment pour la
prochaine réforme des institutions
à l'évidence dans ce pays l'exécutif a
beaucoup trop de pouvoir et le parlement
pas assez on voit que les députés qui
sont élus quasiment en même temps que le
président de la république se contente
de voter les textes du président le
gouvernement et transparent donc à
l'évidence il faut plus de pouvoir pour
le parlement et je crois que la
commission a bien travaillé et elle a
montré l'utilité du sénat très bien
merci beaucoup à hervé marseille d'avoir
étendu à mes questions
merci alexandre poussin pour cette
réaction en direct et on vous explique à
présent avec tan tan et comment les
sénateurs vont saisir la justice pour
parjure devant la commission denquête ou
connaît d'ailleurs la date à laquelle se
réunira le bureau tam est oui a priori
et bien la présidence du sénat nous a
dit que ce bureau devait se réunir le 21
mars est encore à prendre au
conditionnel
on ne sait pas s'il peut y avoir un
bureau exceptionnel autour du cas
benalla ce qu'on sait en tout cas c'est
que mentir sous serment devant la
représentation
nationale c'est un délit qui peut être
puni de cinq ans de prison de 75000
euros d'amendé
la peine peut être portée à sept ans de
prison et 100 mille euros damende en cas
de circonstances aggravantes un les
sénateurs le précisent dans leur
courrier à gérard larcher
ils ont présenté de nombreux faux
témoignages de la part d'alexandre
benalla sur les raisons pour lesquelles
il a obtenu son permis de port d'armes
sur ce qui est arrivé à ces passeports
diplomatiques concernant vincent en kraz
autour de la société velours cette
société de protection rapprochée dont il
avait dit tout ignorer
et puis il ya aussi tous ces moments où
le secrétaire général de l'elysée alexis
kohler patrick strzoda le directeur de
cabinet des manuels macron et le général
lionel lavergne en charge de la sécurité
du président de la république
tous ont retenu une part significative
de la vérité c'est là un euphémisme
employés par les sénateurs qui juge
qu'ils ont entre eux aussi menti en
omettant de dire qu'alexandre benalla
avait une fonction de coordination des
services de sécurité de l'elysée
ou encore quand ils ont nié qu'il avait
une fonction de protection rapprochée du
président de la république bref qu'il
était son garde du corps
les sénateurs en doute très fortement
que va-t-il se passer alors dame alors
fort de tous ces faits je voulais dire
aujourd'hui les sénateurs ont donc
adressé une lettre au président du sénat
c'est en réalité le bureau du sénat
composé de 26 sénateurs
le président les vice présidents les
questeurs mais aussi les secrétaires
tous vont se réunir et vont voter pour
ensuite voir s'il demande au président
du sénat de saisir le parquet de
transmettre tout le dossier au procureur
je le disais normalement tout cela
devrait donc avoir lieu le 21 mars
et c'est donc gérard larcher au final
qui va saisir la justice
et ce dernier ce matin a déclaré qu'ils
étaient prêts la justice qui doit elle
dira s'il ya lieu de donner suite des
suites judiciaires à tout cela on est
dans une situation inédite à tam c'est
quasiment une première
oui la première année très récente
c'était en 2016 un cas de parjure devant
halla de commission d' enquête sur le
coût économique de la pollution de l'air
mais là on est vraiment sur un gars
beaucoup plus important puisque les
sénateurs voit plusieurs catégories 1 de
parjure il ya un les faux témoignages
pour alexandre bédat live instant kraz
ensuite 2
la rétention d'une part significative de
la vérité pour alexis kohler patrick
strzoda et les général lavernhe et enfin
il souhaite même que la justice puisse
étudier l'ensemble du rapport pour voir
s'il ya lieu de procéder à d'autres
investigations
merci à vous attendent pour toutes à ces
précisions autre réaction celle du
sénateur socialiste du val d'oise rachid
tu es mal il est à vos côtés avec 120
pouces à ouïr agité mal que pensez-vous
de justement c'est faux témoignages qui
ont été pointés par le sénat faux
témoignage d'alexandre vialatte de
vincent crasé puis également la
rétention de certaines parties de la
vérité par trois hauts responsables de
l'elysée comme vous le dites c'est
extrêmement grave
d'abord je tiens à saluer le travail de
la commission bancaire du sénat
alors que dans le même temps vous
souvenez vous que la commission denquête
à l'assemblée au bout de trois jours
quatre jours avait été sabordée puisque
à l'époque la présidente vous avez dit
tout connaître de la sphère benalla et
puis ce six mois plus tard on voit bien
qu'il ya encore beaucoup de choses à
démêler d'abord vous l'avez dit monsieur
benalla et monsieur kraz ont menti
maintenant c'est prouvé on l'avait senti
très rapidement et donc maintenant à la
justice vient la demande du présent
marché du présent du sénat de faire son
travail
et puis d'autres hauts responsables et
on l'a bien senti il y avait des
contradictions il y avait des silences
il y avait des jeux de passe passe etc
et on voit bien que là aussi tout n'a
pas été dit et donc malgré leur
engagement leur serment tout n'a pas été
dit ou encore beaucoup de choses doivent
être dites parce que il ya aussi un
élément qui est venu montrer qu'il y
avait quelques problèmes d'une question
de sécurité on a vu tout ça est très
large puisque par exemple à compte la
question des contrats russe on voit bien
que les contrats avec deux oligarques
russes proche de vladimir poutine ont
été signés et on retrouve à la fois le
monsieur sécurité de l'elysée à la fois
le monsieur sécurité des répliques en
marche et à la fois là le compagnon de
la madame sécurité de matignon on peut
s'interroger dans notre république dans
un état quand on sait aujourd'hui à son
dos pratique comment ces trois personnes
ont été mêlés ont signé en travailler
avec deux oligarques russes pour assurer
des questions de sécurité
est-ce que selon vous ça révèle une
certaine pratique du pouvoir aux faits
ou juste un manque de règles dans le
fonctionnement du sommet de l'état
il ya au minimum 1 1 sont de règle après
jeu passif emploie le terme de système
ce qui est clair c'est qu'aujourd'hui il
ya une scission qui n'est pas acceptable
comment accepter que des hauts
dirigeants d'autres pays
je vous cite et roanne ont en tout cas
pour le parti présidentiel est à
l'elysée était apparemment dans le même
temps en train de négocier et de mettre
en place des accords avec avec 2
millions d'euros avec des oligarques
russes tout ça dans quand même nous
interroger il faut des réponses aussi à
ces questions là c'est extrêmement grave
puisque j'espère que ça ne va pas
toucher à la fois à son dos de se créer
un centre de c'est quand même la
question de la france est son
indépendance qui pourraient être
impactés par cette affaire c'est la sécu
sécurité de la france qui est en jeu
en tout cas il la question pourrait se
poser puisque il est habilité secret
défense monsieur bénard je le rappelle
est habilité secret défense et en même
temps ils négocier avec les oligarques
russes pour des questions de sécurité
très bien merci beaucoup racheter mal
d'avoir répondu à ma question merci à
vous alexandre pour cette nouvelle
réaction suite de notre édition spéciale
sur public sénat avec quatre nouveaux
elle invitait qui nous rejoint ce soir
sur ce plateau
isabelle veyrat masson bonsoir vous êtes
directrice de recherche au cnrs
spécialiste de communication médiatique
bienvenue à vous françois noël buffet
est également sur ce plateau bonsoir
vous êtes un sénateur
l ère du rhône vice président de la
commission des lois tout comme louis
jacques bigot vous êtes également
vice-président de cette commission qui a
eu les prérogatives d'une commission
d'enquêté parlementaire pendant sept
mois et vous êtes sénateur socialiste du
bas rhin bruno cautrès est également
avec nous sur ce plateau vous êtes un
chercheur au cnrs au cevipof et
enseignant à sciences po
isabelle veyrat masson on a vu ce
travail du sénat très attendu qu'est ce
que ça dit selon vous justement des
rapports entre l'exécutif et la haute
assemblée saisie qui ne s'entendent pas
très bien si c'est ça que vous voulez me
faire dire et ça pose donc effectivement
on a mis en scène depuis début de l'été
un conflit entre l'exécutif et la haute
assemblée on vous dit
et avec le problème politique de la
légitimité des uns et des autres c'est à
dire que un président de la république
qui a été élu très confortablement
c'est paris craque et une assemblée qui
n'est pas représentatif politiquement de
l'equilibre du pays et donc cette
bagarre me semblait
un peu comment dirais-je
disproportionnée d'abord parce qu'il
s'agissait au départ d'un fait divers un
fait divers peut être mal réglée à terre
de l'elysée probablement sous-estimé par
l'elysée mais qui surtout a pris une
ampleur
alors je me semble-t-il bien bien
exagéré et le fait que le sénat se soit
emparé de la faire avec gourmandise
beaucoup souvent de mauvaise foi posent
la question effectivement de la
légitimité politique du sénat moi je
pensais que les contenus que le coût que
le que compte rendu à led plus moi dans
l'action donc peut-être un peu plus
équilibré j'étais frappé par la
virulence du tout on en parlera
peut-être puisque le virulence du tour
sa compagne d'expression linguistique
qui me semble choquant dans un rapport
aussi accusateurs comme probables faux
témoignages des choses qui laissent à
penser ou qui tentent à établir quand on
fait un procès on ne laisse pas penser
au temps pas établir et on n'est pas
dans la probabilité on est dans des
choses à mon avis plus puissant au liban
certains y ont vu un verdict implacable
blake a une âme bruno cautrès d'effets
visibles même pas en faire une lecture
politique qu'elle veut ce rapport
parlementaire
c'est impossible de parfaire une lecture
un peu politique c'est un c'est un jeu
qui s'est jouée à plusieurs acteurs
d'abord globalement je trouve que le
rapport est fidèle à au rôle qu'a voulu
avoir le sénat et la commission ils ont
été jusqu'au bout leur logique et c'est
effectivement un jeu qui est un jeu qui
sait jouer à plusieurs
il ya aussi l'assemblée nationale qui
était dans ce qui était dans ce jeu là
et peut-être aussi le jeu qu'a joué la
commission du sénat n'est pas
déconnectée du jeu qu'avait joué là en
parallèle la commission à l'assemblée
nationale avec un climat
fondamentalement différent de ce qui se
passait au sénat c'est un jeu qui a
plusieurs aussi parce que eh bien le
sénat n'est pas de la même couleur
politique dans sa majorité que
l'exécutif
donc évidemment il est impossible de ne
pas avoir une lecture politique
ceci dit il faut pas non plus avoir
qu'une lecture politique il ya aussi une
lecture à la fois institutionnelle le
rôle du sénat l'affirmation d'un où
l'heureux l'affirmation d'un
le rôle du sénat dans la travers la
commission denquête et puis aussi quand
même en toile de fond la question
l'ensemble des questions qui sont posées
par la commission et par son rapport
l'entourage de l'exécutif l'entourage
présidentiel donc au minimum le rapport
et la commission denquête ont le mérite
d'avoir posé un regard et d'avoir braqué
les projecteurs sur quelque chose qui
était relativement sombre jusqu'à
présent peu portées à la connaissance du
public
donc il ya quand même une vertu qui
n'est pas inintéressante du point de vue
du processus démocratique du rôle qu'a
joué et le sénat et la commission
jacques bigot ça vous fait réagir
oui cela me fait réagir parce que on ne
peut pas oublier que lorsque la chaire
vénale a éclaté à l'assemblée nationale
il était en plein débat sur la réforme
constitutionnelle
et ce débat a été interrompue parce que
précisément les sénateurs d'opposition
certes mais de droite comme de gauche
posé la question de dire mais vous à
travers une réforme et vous êtes en
train de vouloir priver le parlement de
son existence et de renforcer les
pouvoirs présidentiels et à partir de là
la première commission denquête décidé
ça a été à l'assemblée nationale donc on
était bien dans le rôle des pouvoirs et
je vous rappelle madame que nous sommes
dans un système bicamérisme avec deux
assemblées l'assemblée du sénat a des
pouvoirs législatifs et des pouvoirs de
contrôle au même titre que l'assemblée
nationale et que donc tout sommes
légitimes comme l'assemblée nationale
était la différence est que comme
l'assemblée nationale à une majorité
proches du président de la république
ils se sont vite des fossés de leur
volonté d' enquête alors que au sénat
les choses ont été très régulièrement
fait notamment sur une mission
d'information sur quelques aces qui a
dysfonctionné dans l'organisation de la
sécurité autour du présent la république
et je pense que le rapport dévoile un
certain nombre de choses qui ne sont pas
inintéressantes qui n'en font pas
forcément une histoire d'état
si nous avons des clarifications que
nous avons dû que là les rapporteurs une
président au du mal à obtenir puisque il
a fallu attendre jusqu'au mois d'octobre
2018 pour que enfin la solde de l'elysée
donne la lettre d'engagement et de
mission
de monsieur b nana pour définir
exactement ses missions et ses sept
lettres là qui a révélé que ce qui avait
été dit lors des auditions n'était pas
tout à fait exact qui a quand même un
problème pourquoi veux tu ont caché des
choses dans une société dans laquelle
aujourd'hui nos concitoyens plus que
jamais demande de la transparence et
faisons très attention dans ces débats à
l'heure actuelle que nous avons en
france sur la manière dont on sauvegarde
la démocratie une démocratie ne peut pas
fonctionner sans contre-pouvoir le
président de la république a été élu
avec non le parti est en train de
travailler le président le prime le
pouvoir judiciaire ne contrôle pas une
action politique
il contrôle sur la base du code pénal
alors que le contrôle politique c'est la
démocratie et le président de la
république a été élu par un premier tour
à 24% et un troisième tour puisqu'on
voit bien que le travail du sénat
s'était de marcher sur un fil pendant
sept mois avec justement cette question
de la séparation des pouvoirs il ne
fallait pas empiéter le domaine
judiciaire on vous a beaucoup mis sous
pression
l'audition d'alexandre bel a mis en
examen que va-t-il pouvoir dire ça
c'était une des interrogations france on
a une ride
nous n'avons pas eu le sentiment d'être
quelconque pression et je voudrais
revenir sur les propos qui viennent
d'être tenus de contester la légitimité
du sénat à faire le travail qu'il a fait
cela veut dire si on doit vous écoutez
accepter votre propos c'est que le prêt
dans la république ayant été élu il a
tout pouvoir
pas de possibilité de contre-pouvoir et
que d'ailleurs avec la majorité qu'il a
à l'assemblée nationale on a démontré
par les faits que le système s'est
complètement délité et que le
contre-pouvoir ne pouvait pas exister
et c'est bien parce que le sénat dans
notre organisation institutionnelle
possesseurs des pouvoirs qui lui sont
donnés par la constitution a pu mener
correctement cette commission denquête
en respectant une faut le redire à la
fois bien sûr les procédures judiciaires
engagées combien de fois nous l'avons
répété et en se tenant sur une mission
qui est la sienne qui est le contrôle du
fonctionnement d'un certain nombre
d'institutions dans notre république
pour ne pas dire de dysfonctionnements
on ne peut pas reprocher au sénat
d'avoir exercé un
son droit de l'avoir fait librement et
sans contrainte et de surcroît je pense
que notre système actuel
il a été pour le coup le garant d'un
fonctionnement démocratique claire on
est d'accord ou pas d'accord sur les
conclusions c'est une chose mais le
garant d'un fonctionnement démocratique
de notre territoire de notre système
institutionnel qui sépare qui en tous
les cas traduit le fait que le parlement
contrôle l'exécutif
il était dans son rôle nier cela ou
laissé entendre que ce n'est pas
acceptable quelconque raison de
légitimité c'est affaiblir notre système
et s'est renforcée me semble-t-il
les populistes dont nous n'avons plus
rien à faire et donc ils nous ont placés
dans une situation actuelle dramatique
moi je pense au contraire que cette c2
commission d' enquête sur des faits
aussi faible pas intéressant affaiblit
notre système démocratique laisse entrer
constamment j'ai écouté toutes les deux
les deux commissions j'ai relu le
rapport il ya constamment des allusions
à des choses comme vous dites même
l'utilisation du mot choses qu'on ne
sait pas mais qu'on pourrait savoir on
introduit du doute de la suspicion et la
tension de l'interrogation enfin de
beaucoup ses interrogations et chargé
dessous de sous-entendus de non-dits
auquel personne ne comprend et qui
introduit scène attendant peut-être pas
eu la réponse à toutes leurs questions
ils attisent la commission n'a pas je
lis je lis la commission qu'elle était
la fonction d'alexandre beynat nasa
était le point de départ de la
commission denquête c'est au final donc
veut pas de nom peut t on à l'arc à
comprendre qu'il y à des situations dans
lesquelles qui est ambigu dans lequel
une personne a un nom un chef et chargé
de mission ce qui ne veut rien dire du
tout parce qu'en réalité de notre
fonction une deuxième une troisième est
que c est presque quand un gars
l'essence de sa fonction puisque c'est
un homme finalement de en qui le
président de la république a confiance
on sait très bien comment ça fonctionne
sauf que là c'est quelqu'un qui n'a pas
un casier judiciaire contrairement à ce
qui se passe souvent qui est un militant
à 15 ans il s'engage le parti socialiste
il est je dis revenez pas pardon mais ce
que j'ai reçue que c'est pas un bandit
que le président la revue
alors que depuis enfin moi j'ai vu
passer quelques gouvernement hélas à
l'âge que j'ai et j'ai vu des bonnes
âmes qui entourait les caisses que on
compare les deux génies métier qu'il a
pu avoir au sein de la commission il ya
quand même trois absents trois
abstentions les deux sénateurs en marche
le sénateur non inscrit de la moselle a
expliqué son vote au micro d'alexandre
poussard écouter jean louis masson vous
êtes l'un des trois sénateurs à s'être
abstenus lors du vote du rapport de la
commission denquête benalla pour quelles
raisons alors tout d'abord j'aurais vous
direz vous le savez je ne suis pas du
tout un soutien de monsieur macron et je
ne te considère que la sphère benalla
est un scandale d'état
ceci étant il faut faire les choses
correctement ce rapport sur la
commission d' enquête parlementaire
était en rapports importants
or nous avons été prévenus deux jours
avant seulement deux jours avant de ce
que l'ordre du jour de la commission ont
été changés et qu'on passait le rapport
alors sur un dossier aussi important on
ne prévient pas les gens deux jours
avant deuxième chose on y arrivait en
commission on n'avait aucun document
on nous a mis le rapport sur la table et
on lui a dit approuver le rapport vient
ça c'est pas possible moi je n'ai pas
pour habitude d'approuver et d'endosser
la responsabilité d'un rapport qui fait
60 pages et qu'on vous met sur la table
en vous disant vous approuvez rapport où
vous vous y opposer je crois qu'il y
avait quelque chose qui n'allait pas je
l' ai bien dit c'est un problème de
forme
il y avait dans cette commission a
certain nombre de sénateurs qui avait la
volonté de faire de l'agitation
politicienne auprès des journalistes
c'est leur droit moi je voulais du
travail sérieux le président a fait du
travail sérieux les rapporteurs ont fait
du travail sérieux mais certains
sénateurs ont fait surtout de
l'agitation journalistique vous êtes
d'accord donc avec certains
parlementaires la république en marche
qui affirme que le sénat fait de la
politique dans cette affaire moi je n'ai
pas être d'accord ou pas d'accord avec
certains parlementaires
de la république en marche je ne partage
pas les choix politiques de la
république en marche et quand je me dis
si je me décide toujours par moi même je
suis non inscrits parce que j'ai une
très mauvaise opinion des partis
politiques
je suis comme beaucoup de français je
pense comme beaucoup de français sur les
partis politiques et je considère qu' il
faut soi-même assumer ses
responsabilités et ce matin j'ai dit
assumer vous êtes donc en désaccord sur
la forme mais sur le fond est ce que
vous êtes d'accord avec les
dysfonctionnements pointés par la
commission denquête c'est évident qu'il
ya des dissensions des
dysfonctionnements énormes
par contre je pense qu'on aurait pu
s'abstenir de vouloir mettre en cause
devoir faire engager des plaintes contre
certains hauts fonctionnaires je parle
pas de monsieur benalla bien évidemment
certains hauts fonctionnaires de
l'elysée des anciens précieux colère
monsieur strzoda je crois que ce sont
des gens a priori très bien je les
connais pas mais ils m'ont fait très
bonne impression
vouloir les faire poursuivre alors que
la commission était vraiment en limite
des compétences de la justice vous savez
que la commission n'a pas le droit de
s'immiscer dans une affaire qui est
engagée au niveau judiciaire
on était limites et ses hauts
fonctionnaires étaient très gênés parce
qu'on était en limite et vouloir les
poursuivre maintenant au niveau de la
justice c'est peut-être excessif très
bien merci beaucoup jean louis masson
avait répondu à mes questions
merci à vous à alexandre il fait
allusion en lui massant un autre volet
de ce rapport parlementaire puisque il
ya donc faux témoignage selon vous à la
fois de la part d'alexandre au bénin et
vincent kra et puis il ya les cas de
trois hauts fonctionnaires de l'elysée
ça a été rappelé patrick son d'alexis
colère et puis le colonel lavergne alors
là le sénat a décidé bien de laisser
l'appréciation bureau du sénat pour
savoir s'il ya et bien faux témoignage
et suite je voudrais juste dire qu'un
ciel gymnase de faux témoignages je
reprends le texte de rapport mais de
probables faux témoignage ce qui n'est
pas la même chose
probable ça veut dire qu'il ya pas de
preuve que ce n'est pas sûr et que des
entraînements ça peut être l'un verse
donc tous ces mots probable soupçonneux
mérite d'être d'être aussi levons les
premiers jours par les dons je suis beau
témoignage alors qu'on ne parle que de
mon rapport
j'ai axé un rapport utilise le langage
de la probabilité le rapport lui-même
fait un noceur d'exercice au peu de
modestie aussi sur lui-même accusateur
mais si langage un langage utilisé un
langage de probabilités il va remettre
effectivement au bureau la
responsabilité de d'aller un peu plus
loin et de voir ce qu'il faut faire
vous aurez aux autorités judiciaires et
évidemment sur le sur le fond on voit
bien que c'est très compliqué il n'y a
pas de je pense pas qu est tout blanc
est tout noir de mais je pense qu'il ya
quelque chose qui est très compliqué
mais au delà de quelque chose qui est
très compliqué je persiste à dire quand
même que à travers cette commission
denquête à travers le rapport qu'elle
remet il ya plutôt un progrès
intéressants d'une démocratie où le
contrôle parlementaire sur l'exécutif
fonctionne je rejoins vos propos je
pense qu'effectivement ce point qui est
essentiel la france et 1 en ce moment
traversé par de grands débats sur
l'avenir des institutions sur qu'est ce
qu'il faut faire pour que ça aille mieux
qu'ils aient plus de confiance des
citoyens dans la politique on abaisse le
niveau de violence verbale le niveau
d'intolérance dans l'ensemble de la
société
c'est un enjeu qui est extrêmement
essentiel extrêmement important la
question de la restauration du lien de
confiance des citoyens dans les
institutions est absolument centrale
l'enquète qu'une réalisons cevipof
toutes les années montre que la
situation est calamiteuse en france si
les institutions arrive à montrer
qu'elle fonctionne qu elles font
fonctionner leurs prérogatives leur
pouvoir c'est plutôt une bonne chose
pour le rac le regard que les citoyens
pose sur les sur les institutions après
chacun fera son travail dira ainsi la
commission excédé ses pouvoirs etc
mais du point de vue de l'analyse
politique compo témoignage sans crainte
je repars le probable faux témoignage
verrez je veux être clair lorsque la
commission denquête auditionne monsieur
benalla et qu'il dit à la commission
j'ai restituer les passeports je les ai
laissés à l'elysée et qu'on découvre
ultérieurement en auditionnant des gens
de l'elysée qu'en fait il ne les a pas
rendu et qu'il n'a fallu attendre le
mois de janvier le fait que le ministre
des affaires étrangères qu'on a
conditionné aussi et puis dire on a su
qu'il les a utilisé à plusieurs reprises
ces passeports diplomatiques ou ces
passeports de service
donc ils les avaient manifestement il
n'a pas dit la vérité mais lorsque l'on
adresse une lettre au bureau du sénat
qui a compétence pour de transmettre le
cas échéant procure de la république qui
seul peut engager des poursuites
le sénat ne peut pas engager poursuites
à l'égard de monsieur ben là c'est au
procureur de la république d'apprécier
double idée du probable leur se
consolerait le broker c'est au procureur
de juger s'il considère que la 10e
suffisant et ensuite à la justice
vous avez fait cette observation tout à
l'heure là on est vraiment dans le
respect absolu de la séparation des
pouvoirs à l'égard du pouvoir judiciaire
tous cas à faire de quelqu'un a prêté
serment il peut être sanctionnée
pénalement mais c'est du ressort du
procureur de la république est derrière
eux des juridictions qui seront le cas
échéant saisit donc on est bien sûr une
probabilité est pas une certitude
n'avons pas affirmer des certitudes nous
ne jugeons pas nous alexandre banal
débat sur ce champ françois noël buffet
pour ce qui est des fonctionnaires on
parle de rétention d'information la st
ce qu'il est important de se reporter au
rapport d'une part mais surtout à la
lettre du président de la commission des
loi cosignée par les rapporteurs
adressée au président du sénat qui va
saisir le bureau
dans ce court dans ce courrier ils
viennent note très précises sur qui est
intitulée liste des incohérences et
contradictions relevé et il ya des
choses très clair celui concernant le
premier point sur le périmètre des
missions exercées par monsieur alexandre
benalla au regard des documents qu'elle
a recueilli la commission a pu établir
que plusieurs personnes entendues ont
menti c'est pas probablement ont menti
sur le périmètre exact des missions qui
étaient confirme cieux bien
antti autti oui après vous et le détail
je peux vous lire la lettre non mais on
peut jouer sur les mots ça peut durer ça
peut durer non parce qu'il ya une
démonstration ensuite je vous invite à
la lire vraiment je sais pas si vous
l'avez eue je vous invite à la lire
démonstration en fonction des
déclarations avec une mise en lumière
des contradictions donc les choses sont
claires c'est vrai pour d'autres
paragraphe voilà lorsque je veux dire
c'est qu'effectivement si le procureur
est saisi il garde l'opportunité des
poursuites
et c'est très bien comme ça il n'y a pas
de discussions et il décidera ce qu'il
veut pour ce qui concerne ni monsieur
bennani monsieur kraz les autres
personnes
la commission les rapporteurs ont relevé
en fonction des pièces qu'ils ont été
communiqués mais également des
déclarations qui ont été faites des
contradictions qui lesquels
contradictions traduisent qu'il ya
vraiment une grande différence entre ce
qu'ils ont accepté de dire à la
commission
et si quelle est la réalité des fêtes on
connaît un certain de ces personnes sont
des gens de qualité par ailleurs n'y a
pas de difficultés là dessus mais il ya
ces contradictions et qu'il constitue à
l'évidence une vraie distorsion sur le
fond des choses
j'allais presque dire le procureur
appréciera si les saisies naturellement
avec le bureau de l'autorisation
nous en sommes là il avait levé
relations il ya quand même des
préconisations pour plus de transparence
qui appelle à la prudence dans le
recrutement à des collaborateurs à
l'elysée on peut être que d'accord avec
ceux proposés
alors on peut être d'un que d'accord
comme avec bruno cautrès lorsqu'il dit
qu'il est important qu'il y ait des
contre-pouvoirs qu'il y ait de la
transparence et que l'on doit se
féliciter qu'une démocratie fonctionne
avec les trolls et les pouvoirs des
pouvoirs séparés mais qui secoue qui se
contrôlent mutuellement
bien évidemment avec le risque quand
même que lorsque ça se passe mal on met
là une interrogation sur le sur le
principe même c'est à dire que si vous
vous servez d'une bonne idée pour la
détourner de sa véritable fonction
c'est-à-dire que si les commissions
deviennent des armes politiques
au contraire ça peut faire un effet
boomerang qui serait négatif sur le
fonctionnement de la démocratie
par exemple je trouve que ces
commissions auraient dû être non pas
aurait dû être dans le secret tu sais
que c'est pour laisser les gens
s'exprimer librement
pour ne pas les autres
j'ai a dénoncé devant bfm lci et c'est
leur copain qui leur ont fait je ne sais
quoi qu elles l ont été demandées ils
ont tous été refusés justement ça change
tout je veux dire un fonds que c'est
pour ça qu'il ya un pouvoir judiciaire
et voir les stats y faire voir et qui
tue si chacun à des logiques différentes
donc je ne suis pas sûr que les bons
principes soient à 2 ce soir lorsqu'ils
marchent mal soit finalement positif est
en revanche évidemment les
préconisations
on voit d'ailleurs elle porte la marque
altman départ puisque lorsqu'on voit la
séparation entre le pool le public est
prêt on voit bien qu'une des reproches
que l'on fait à fermer nahla c'est le
fait que le président a brigué choisi
d'utiliser quelqu'un qui vient du privé
et non pas fonctionnaire la séparation
on a annulé pour conclure alors depuis
le phare en fait à faire la vraie
question c'est que il n'y a pas eu de
sanctions
les faits ont été cachés on a laissé sur
les réseaux sociaux circuler cette
fameuse vidéo et nous nous avons les
premiers auditions de avons eue c'était
des représentants des syndicats de
police qui disait ça donnait sur la
police une très mauvaise image l'image
de violence alors que ce n'était pas des
policiers
il aurait suffi que au niveau du sommet
de l'état on dit simplement monsieur
benalla vous n'avez plus rien à faire
ici on vous licencie tout de suite et
que l'on dise effectivement ce qui
s'était passé il n'y aurait pas eu
d'affaires benalla et ça ça le mot de la
fin et c'est ce qu'ont d'ailleurs ce
qu'a rappelé philippe bas à l'ouverture
de la conférence de presse ce matin
merci à vous françois noël buffet merci
à isabelle veyrat masson merci et bruno
cautrès merci à jacques bigot avant de
se quitter je songe à proposer de
revenir sur les temps forts de cette
conférence de presse et bien c'est un
best-of préparé par alice bardot en
bordant strictement notre examen à des
questions relatives au fonctionnement de
l'état nous avons réuni suffisamment
d'éléments pour estimer que la sécurité
du président de la république a été
affectée que de nombreuses erreurs ou
anomalies et défaillances ont été
constatées sanction insuffisante au
départ
justice tenue à l'écart permis de port
d'armes irrégulier portes d'une arme par
monsieur benalla en présence du
président de la république non respect
des règles de déontologie sur les
conflits d'intérêts maintien en
possession de monsieur benhaddad un
téléphone cris et de passeport
diplomatique ou de service qu'ils n'ont
pas été récupérées absence d'
instructions données à la police de
l'air et des frontières de ne pas
permettre à monsieur benalla de sortir
au moyen de ces passeports diplomatique
ou de service
cela fait tout de même beaucoup c'est
bien que les faits constatés le premier
mais apparaissent maintenant comme la
partie émergée d'un iceberg
du point de vue du bon fonctionnement de
l'état les informations qui se sont
accumulés ensuite sont sans doute plus
grave encore que les événements survenus
en marge de la fête du travail comme l'
ordonnance de 1958 relative à l'exercice
de ses pouvoirs dans quête par le
parlement le prévoit j'ai donc décidé
conjointement avec les deux rapporteurs
et après avoir consulté ce matin la
commission des lois de demander au
président du sénat que le bureau de
notre assemblée c'est la procédure
délibère en vue de saisir le procureur
de la république de paris
des faux témoignages caractérisée de
monsieur benalla des contradictions
apparues entre les premières
déclarations de collaborateurs immédiats
du président de la république sur le
rôle de monsieur benalla en matière de
sécurité et les éléments et témoignages
recueillis par la suite tout en
soulignant d'ailleurs la qualité et la
précision de nombreuses informations qui
nous ont été apportées par les dix
collaborateurs sur d'autres points très
importants
nous souhaitons aussi que l'ensemble du
rapport soit lui-même transmis au
procureur de la république afin qu'il
puisse apprécier l'existence éventuelle
d'autres faux témoignage susceptible
d'avoir été commis par des personnes
auditionnées
il appartiendra donc au bureau d'en
décider et les deux rapporteurs se
joignent à moi
pour faire cette demande au bureau
madame jourdain
merci monsieur présidente de me donner
la parole pour présenter effectivement
d'une façon synthétique mais que nous
pensons néanmoins complète les travaux
que nous avons menées autour de quatre
points que je qualifierais de clés qui
nous sont apparus au fur et à mesure de
nos travaux le premier point est
relative aux sanctions aux sanctions qui
ont pu être prononcée à l'encontre
d'alexandre benalla après le 1er mai
événements qui ont d'abord justifié la
tenue de nos travaux en réalité
plusieurs défaillances ont été mises à
jour dans la réaction des autorités
fonctionnel hiérarchique de monsieur
benalla est également de vincent kraz
qui participaient aux événements du 1er
mai après ces événements je le dis sans
ambages la commission n'a trouvé ni
approprié les premières suites qui ont
été apportées aux agissements commis ni
proportionnée
les sanctions qui ont été prétendument
infligées et nous avons regretté
l'incompréhensible indulgence de la
hiérarchie d'alexandre benalla qui a
conservé dans l'équipe de l'elysée un
collaborateur qui avait gravement manqué
à ses devoirs etc en génie qu'il avait
gravement manqué à ses devoirs
ça n'est pas de mon avis c'est de l'avis
de toutes les personnes qui ont été
auditionnées par la commission
ce qui frappe en réalité ce n'est pas
tant la sanction qui a été infligé en
mai mais bien la confiance qui a été
maintenu à alexandre benalla jusqu'en
juillet
tout d'abord nous avons pu constater ce
que je qualifierais d'une chaîne
d'irresponsabilité en l'absence de
signalement immédiat au parquet de ces
faits rappelons-nous revêtu d'un signe
de police selon l'igpn est peut-être
armée sur la voie publique pour l'un
d'eux alexandre benalla et vincent kraz
ont ouvertement le 1er mai 2018 fait
usage de la force à l'encontre de
manifestants
les suites pénales aujourd'hui de la
justice mais ces faits présentait déjà
pour les autorités fonctionnaires
informer tous les indices qui permettait
d'envisager la commission d'un délit et
il appartenait donc à ses fonctionnaires
informer en toute hypothèse de soumettre
la qualification de ces faits au parquet
en application l'article 40 du code de
procédure pénale
de façon assez surprenante c'est la
présidence de la république et non pas
le ministère de l'intérieur qui a été
alertée la première dans la nuit du 1er
mai de l'existence d'une vidéo vidéos
des incidents et c'est également la
présidence de la république qui a
transmis l'information au ministre de
l'intérieur et au préfet de police
al'inverse plusieurs services plusieurs
services clés dont l'intervention aurait
pu perturber le règlement discret de
cette affaire benalla et bien ont été
maintenus dans l'ignorance jusqu'en
juillet 2018
ni la direction générale de la police
nationale ni l'inspection générale de la
police nationale ni la direction
générale de la gendarmerie nationale
dont été avisé des faits aucune des
autorités qu'ils étaient informés
aucune de ces autorités c'est à dire
l'elysée la préfecture de police le
ministère de l'intérieur qui connaissait
ses agissements ne les a signalé au
procureur de paris
chacune se défaussant a posteriori sur
l'autre de la responsabilité du
signalement ce que nous en avons déduit
c'est que bien loin du traitement et
hiérarchique normale rapide rigoureux et
qu aurait mérité un événement impliqué
un agent de l'elysée de ce niveau de
surcroît ces dysfonctionnements témoigne
de la fébrilité de l'exécutif face à un
risque politique et risques que
représentait la diffusion de cette vidéo
sur internet et donne le sentiment que
l'elysée a vainement il faut dire
souhaitait se réserver le traitement du
problème pour se préserver d'un possible
scandale
voilà quelles sont les premières
conclusions sur cette chaîne des
responsabilités
s'agissant toujours des suites données
aux événements du 1er mai rencontre
monsieur benalla je dois dire que nous
émettons des doutes assez clair sur
l'effectivité réel des sanctions qui ont
été infligés les informations qui
étaient recueillies par la commission
sur la portée réelle des sanctions
prononcées à l'encontre d'alexandre
benalla mais également de vincent kraz
ont permis de démentir plusieurs
explications qui avait été donnée par le
porte parole du président de la
république lors d'une conférence de
presse donnée à l'elysée le 19 juillet
2018 et qui avait fortement exagérée me
semble-t-il la réalité de la sanction
prononcée en mai concernant la mise à
pied de quinze jours qui était annoncé
d'alexion de benalla par l'elysée
vincent crasse par le parti en marche
les auditions de notre commission ont
révélé qu'elle ne se sont en fait
traduite par aucune conséquence
financière immédiate pour les intéressés
et à ce jour nous n'avons d'ailleurs pas
la certitude que la conséquence
financière était réel concernant la
rétrogradation dont l'action de bélaye
censé avoir fait l'objet sa hiérarchie
avait mis en avant le retrait à titre de
sanction des compétences en matière de
déplacements officiels du président de
la république
toutefois il a été confirmé à notre
commission que cette décision était
provisoire et compensé par l'attribution
de nouvelles tâches et surtout ce
principe de rétrogradation a été
assortie d'importantes exception
participation à la panthéonisation de
simone veil le 1er juillet également
cérémonies du 14-juillet fait non
négligeable pour les français au retour
de l'équipe de france de football le 16
juillet et surtout maintien de
l'accompagnement des déplacements privés
du président de la république sanctions
mais surtout confiance maintenue ainsi
que je le disais en préambule
alexandre bédat à conserver enfin des
moyens qui étaient inchangées ses
passeports ces véhicules voire renforcée
puisque à logements de fonction lui a
été attribué à la mi juin alors qu'il
avait été sanctionné et il continuer de
participer à la réflexion sur la mise en
place de la future direction de la
sécurité du président de la république
la commission estime donc que ces
décisions témoigne d'une volonté - de
sanctionner que de ménager dans
l'immédiat l'exposition médiatique
d'alexandre benalla dans un contexte
délicat
voilà le premier point clé sur lequel
nous souhaitions faire part de nos
conclusions la commission également
réuni des éléments concordants donnant à
penser qu alexandre benalla exercer dans
les faits une mission et une fonction de
protection rapprochée du président de la
république ce qui a été pourtant
obstinément nier par les principaux
responsables de l'elysée que nous avons
reçues
en atteste tout d'abord son
positionnement permanent à proximité
immédiate du chef de l'état lors des
déplacements auxquels ils participaient
qui de l'avis d'experts correspondrait à
une position des pôles je cite entre
guillemets chargés d'évacuer le
président de la république dans des
cités ci dans des situations extrêmes
justifié par le besoin de passer des
messages au chef de l'état un tel
positionnement paraît pourtant n'avoir
jamais été adopté par aucun des
prédécesseurs ni aucun des collègues
d'alexandre benalla surtout le permis de
port d'armes et j'insiste là-dessus qui
lui a été attribué en octobre 2017 par
la préfecture de police dans des
conditions inédites et dérogatoire au
droit commun
à tel point que l'intéressé lui même
avait envisagé à défaut un décret secret
du président de la république pour
l'autoriser à porter une arme et nous en
fournit sont la preuve
cela ne pouvait se justifier par
d'autres raisons qu'une fonction de
protection rapprochée
le soutien appuyé de sa hiérarchie à la
demande qu'il avait formulées de même
que les contradictions devant la
commission des collaborateurs du
président de la république pour
justifier ce permis de port d'armes
accréditent l'idée qu'alexandre benalla
exercé des missions de protection
rapprochée requérant contrairement à ses
collègues le port d'une arme
il a par ailleurs reconnu avoir porté
cette arme en présence du président de
la république ce qui est sans précédent
par rapport à un certain nombre de
situations identiques par le passé nous
avons été alertés fin décembre par
plusieurs articles de presse et dès
janvier nous avons mené une nouvelle
audition une nouvelle investigation et
nous avons eu alors la confirmation que
les diligences minimales nécessaires
pour garantir la pleine application de
l'ascension licenciement de l'ex en
benalla n'avait pas été accompli par la
présidence de la république et les
ministères concernés notamment pour
s'assurer de la restitution
son départ des moyens dont ils
disposaient uniquement pour l'exercice
de ses fonctions
le premier moyen dont il s'agit et le
téléphone théorème dans lequel on a pu
noter pour lequel on a pu noter un
manque de diligence regrettable des
services alors même qu'il s'agissait
d'un moyen de communication hautement
sécurisé qui a été présenté comme
nécessaire à l'exercice des missions de
la chefferie de cabinet encore que nous
avons pu nous convaincre de ce que
personne avant ni après monsieur b
lalanne a estimé nécessaire à ses
fonctions ce téléphone théorème pour
autant c'est un moyen hautement
sécurisés et la présidence de la
république ne s'est pas aperçue au
moment de l'inventaire du bureau de
monsieur b dallas qui a eu lieu le 2
août de la non restitution de ce
terminal théorème la présidence d'un
public ne va s'en apercevoir qu en
octobre 2018
à l'occasion du recensement de
l'intégralité des appareils qui sont mis
à disposition
c'est à dire plusieurs mois après la
date effective du licenciement
en outre après qu en octobre 2018 la
disparition a été découverte
l'elysée ne s'est pas assuré que
l'appareil était restitué l'elysée cette
uniquement assuré qu'il avait été
désactivé à distance et qu'il n'a pas
été utilisé aucune demande de
restitution de l'équipement n'a été
adressée à l'ancien chargé de mission et
ce n'est qu'en janvier 2019 que ce
terminal a été rendue sur proposition
d'ailleurs du conseil d' alexandre
bédard le deuxième série de
dysfonctionnements
s'agissant des restitutions de
restitution des moyens mis à disposition
de monsieur benalla est relative à ces
passeports lorsqu'il était en fonction à
l'elysée alexandre bédat disposait de
pas moins de quatre passeports
professionnels deux passeports
diplomatiques et deux passeports de
service
aucun n'a été restituée lors de son
licenciement
ces passeports diplomatiques ont été en
revanche utilisé à une vingtaine de
reprises 23 selon l'intéressé lui-même
entre le 1er août et le 31 décembre 2018
pour seront notamment au tchad en israël
et est probablement au maroc et aux
bahamas
ces passeports ont d'abord été attribuée
dans des conditions qui étaient énormes
l'attribution simultanée de quatre
passeports professionnels ne semble ni
courante ni justifiées à ce niveau de
responsabilité mise en avant dès le
début des travaux de notre commission le
manque de précautions et de diligence la
présidence de la république dans la
prévention des conflits d'intérêts de
certains de ses collaborateurs pendant
ou après l'exercice de leurs fonctions
s'est confirmée au fil des révélations
sur l' affaire dite des contrats russe
la commission n'a pas pu procéder sur ce
sujet à des demandes d'informations
complémentaires dans les délais impartis
à l'exercice des pouvoirs
d'investigation qui lui ont été
consentis par le sénat pour six mois le
23 juillet 2018
elle tire néanmoins des informations
qu'elle a réuni trois conclusions
majeures d'abord en matière de faux
témoignages les informations révélées
par la presse en particulier les
enregistrements qui ont donné lieu à
diverses péripéties parues dans la
presse également les enregistrements
donc publié par le journal mediapart le
31 juillet janvier 2019 et les
déclarations publiques faites par
monsieur jean maurice bernard président
d'une société qui dans le contexte où
nous sommes s'appelle bizarrement
velours velours
le 11 février sur bfm tv laisse à penser
qu alexandre benalla et vincent kraz se
sont rendus coupables lors de leur
audition devant la commission des lois
du sénat le 21 janvier de faux
témoignages premièrement eux sur les
trois points suivants premièrement
l'implication d'alexandre benalla dans
la négociation et la conclusion du
contrat liant la société mars ont pas le
velours mars à et un représentant de
l'oligarque russe monsieur iskander
makhmoudov profondément lié à monsieur
poutine d'ailleurs comme l'a dit je
crois que c'est notre président ce matin
il y à peu d'oligarques russes qui ne
soit pas lié
monsieur poutine deuxième point
l'engagement des négociations en vue de
la conclusion de ce contrat dès le mois
de mars 2018 j'attire l'attention
mesdames et messieurs sur cette date
dès le mois de mars 2018 alors que
alexandre benalla et vincent grass était
encore en fonctions à l'elysée
troisièmement l'implication de vincent
crasse dans la reprise du contrat à
compter d'octobre ou 2018 par une
nouvelle société dont il nous a dit
qu'ils s'appellent joue quoi france
clause protection enfants en français
dans le texte
d'autres monsieur kraz nous a dit que
c'était par une coïncidence qu'elle
avait été créé le jour où l'autre avait
été fermée justement à la même adresse
ce que nous avons écouté avec attention
comme toujours
deuxième point un g10 trois conclusions
majeures ça c'est la première conclusion
deuxième conclusion les révélations sur
la sphère des contrats russe tendent à
établir l'existence de conflits
d'intérêts majeurs
l'implication de monsieur alexandre
benallal monsieur vincent grass dans la
négociation et la conclusion d'activités
de nature privée qui plus est pour le
compte de sociétés appartenant à des
intérêts étrangers puissant donc adjoint
au chef de cabinet qui négocie avec une
société d intérêts financiers liés
directement à un état étranger est au
plus haut niveau de cet état étranger
constituerez non seulement une faute
déontologique majeur pour les intéressés
mais également un risque pour la
présidence de la république et pour
notre république il ne fait en effet nul
doute que les relations indirectes
entretenu avec un oligarque russe par un
proche collaborateur du chef de l'état
directement impliqués on l'a vu dans la
sécurité de la présidence de la
république et d'un réserviste du
commandement militaire du palais de
l'élysée exercer une responsabilité
d'encadrement seraient de nature en
raison de dépendance de la dépendance
financière qu'elle implique a affecté la
sécurité du chef de l'état et les
intérêts de notre pays nous allons faire
13 propositions
alors bien entendu dans le respect de
leur respect je vais présenter six
propositions et muriel jourda on
présentera sept
ça va
alors première proposition
on développera si vous avez des
questions pour le moment on va les
énoncés première proposition réformer le
cadre réglementaire relatif au groupe de
sécurité de la présidence de la
république gspr afin d'une part de
réaffirmer la compétence exclusive des
membres des forces de sécurité
intérieure pour assurer la sécurité du
chef de l'état d'autre part formaliser
les règles et procédures de recrutement
au sein de ce gspr proposition numéro 2
maintenir la responsabilité organique du
ministère de l'intérieur sur le groupe
de sécurité de la présidence de la
république
ce qui nous paraît absolument essentiel
sur le plan des institutions
républicaines
ç'a toujours été comme ça depuis le
début de la vème république
je le rappelle t-on maintenir la
responsabilité organique du ministère de
l'intérieur sur le groupe de sécurité de
la présidence de la république et
prévoir la vie du chef du service de la
protection sur la composition de ce
groupe proposition numéro 3 rappelé par
voie de circulaire les règles
déontologiques devant régir les
relations entre les collaborateurs de la
présidence de la république ceux des
cabinets ministériels et les
administrations centrales proposition
numéro 4 mettre fin à l'expérience des
collaborateur officieux du président de
la république et faire respecter
strictement leurs obligations
déclaratives à tous les chargés de
mission de l'elysée proposition numéro 5
conditionner le recrutement des
collaborateurs du président de la
république à la réalisation d'une
enquête administrative préalable afin de
s'assurer de la compatibilité de leur
comportement avec les fonctions ou des
missions susceptibles de leur être
confiées proposition numéro 6 prévoir
par la loi des sanctions pénales en cas
de manquement aux obligations de
déclaration d'une nouvelle activité
à la commission de déontologie de la
fonction publique qui n'a pas été fait
dans le cas de monsieur benalla ni avant
ni bien sûr après maintenant je vais
terminer pour les six propositions et
madame jourdain
ainsi monsieur le président la
proposition numéro 7 a trait directement
à notre saisine qui avait mis en avant
un dysfonctionnement l'état qui
consistait pour un collaborateur de
l'elysée à intervenir dans une mission
de maintien de l'ordre qui relèvent
elles de l'action du gouvernement si
l'exécutif est constitué de deux pôles
le président de la république et le
gouvernement
ils ne doivent pas interférer dans
l'action l'un de l'autre de sorte que
notre proposition numéro 7 est de mettre
fin à la pratique des conseillers
communs aux présidents de la république
et au premier ministre pour respecter la
distinction constitutionnel des
fonctions présidentielles et
gouvernementales seul le gouvernement
étant responsable devant le parlement la
proposition numéro en numéro 8 dans le
cadre d'une plus grande transparence et
d'enrichir leurs rapports déposés
annuellement lors de l'examen du projet
de loi de finances les connaisseurs
selon ce que c'est que la nex budgétaire
jaune ce rapport étant consacré aux
personnels affectés dans les cabinets
ministériels l'enrichir d'un volet
supplémentaire permettant de dresser un
tableau du nombre des missions et des
rémunérations des personnels affectés à
la présidence de la république
la proposition numéro 9 consiste à
renforcer la transparence des
recrutements dans les différentes
réserves de la gendarmerie nationale et
la rigueur des règles de sélection dans
la composante spécialiste de sa réserve
opérationnelle avec un référentiel de
compétences techniques ou théoriques
rechercher un niveau élevé de formation
ou d'expérience professionnelle
nécessaire pour postuler vérification
une appréciation préalable par un jury
pour préparer et appuyer la décision du
directeur général
la proposition numéro 10 consiste à
rendre obligatoire l'établissement d'une
liste des activités professionnelles
exercées par les réservistes du
commandement militaire du palais de
l'elysée les deux autres propositions 11
et 12 12 ont trait au renforcement des
pouvoirs du contrôle du parlement la
proposition numéro
consiste à conforter le pouvoir de
contrôle du parlement sur les services
sur les services de la présidence de la
république non patiente président la
république mais bien sûr les services de
la présidence de la république
la proposition numéro 12 consiste à
établir et confirmé la plénitude des
pouvoirs d'investigation des commissions
d'enquêté parlementaires dans le respect
du principe de la séparation des
pouvoirs du secret de l'instruction
y compris quand la justice enquête de
son côté sur des crimes et délits à
propos des mêmes faits en exerçant le
contrôle parlementaire sous l'angle
exclusif du fonctionnement de l'état
je peux peut-être illustré monsieur le
président cette proposition car il y à
une nombreux débats sur le fait que
notre commission puisse enquêter alors
que la justice était saisie sur des
faits qui était proche dont on pouvait
penser qu'ils étaient similaires et nous
avons toujours défendu le fait que la
justice et le parlement bénéficier de
pouvoirs qui étaient concurrents et de
même valeur constitutionnelle mais ne
s'exerçait pas sur les mêmes éléments ce
qui est expliqué très bien par le
président bah tout à l'heure puisque
nous nous exerçons le contrôle du
fonctionnement de l'état et nous pouvons
dire qu'à l'occasion de notre mission
nous avons été suivis par la justice car
nous avions demandé au ministère de
l'intérieur
un dossier qui avait été saisi et mis
sous scellés le ministère de l'intérieur
nous l'a refusée pour ce motif
nous sommes donc adressé au juge
d'instruction qui détenait ce dossier eh
bien il a tout simplement lever les
scellés est rendu ce dossier au
ministère pour que nous puissions lui
refaire cette demande le juge a donc
estimé que nous pouvions obtenir cet
élément quand bien même une enquête
judiciaire était en cours mais il est
important
par cette proposition de clarifier ces
éléments et enfin la proposition numéro
13 consiste à mieux définir la portée
juridique d obligation de signalement au
parquet découlant l'article 40 du code
de procédure pénale et d'en informer
largement l'ensemble des élus
responsables et agents publics voilà
monsieur le président merci
chers collègues j'espère que les travaux
de nos rapporteur de la commission des
lois seront utiles qui seront utiles aux
français bien sûr puisque notre travail
s'est fait en toute transparence sous
leur regard et en leur nom mais aussi
utile à l'exécutif par les
recommandations qui viennent de vous est
présentée et dont j'espère que elles
apparaîtront pour ce qu'elles sont c'est
à dire des recommandations constructives
dont une partie d'ailleurs vise
simplement à ce que les règles soient
respectées
j'aurais revenir un instant sur la
lettre que nous avons écrite au
président du sénat pour que le bureau du
sénat soit saisi pour indiquer la
motivation fondamentale qui a été la
mienne et celle des deux rapporteurs
il s'agit pour nous en pensant au
respect des prérogatives nécessaires du
parlement pour eux l'avenir de poser une
exigence l'exigence de dire la vérité au
parlement et cette exigence qui existe
dans l' ordonnance de 1958 ne doit pas
rester lettre morte car sinon c'est un
droit essentiel que nous exerçons au nom
du peuple français qui seraient bafoués
et c'est la seule raison pour laquelle
nous avons souhaité que le bureau
délibère il y a trois points différents
comme l'a dit déjà monsieur bah est à
trois points différents
premièrement s'agissant de monsieur
benalla et de monsieur kraz au vu des
travaux de la commission
les informations collecte collecter et
aider au vu des travaux de la commission
des informations collectées et de
plusieurs déclarations sous serment de
monsieur alexandre banana et vincent
kraz dont le détail figure en annexe du
présent courrier
nous sommes conduits à considérer que
celles ci constituent des faux
témoignages
premier point deuxième point s'agissant
des trois personnes déjà cité de
l'elysée monsieur strzoda monsieur
colère et monsieur lavergne il est fait
état d informations qu'ils ont apportés
et il est dit que notre enquête a mis à
jour dans leurs déclarations un certain
nombre d'omissions d'incohérences et de
contradictions dont leur élevé figure en
annexe
et nous disons que qu'ils ont retenues
je prends les termes exacts une part
significative de la vérité à la
commission lors de leurs auditions
notamment sur le périmètre de la mission
de sécurité exercées par monsieur
benalla dès lors nous demandons au
bureau au pré saint au bureau du sénat
de faire part de ces éléments et enfin
troisièmement et je me permets
d'insister là dessus
notre lettre comprend cet élément nous
saisissons le parking vous proposons de
saisir le parquet afin qu'ils apprécient
s'il ya lieu de procéder à des
investigations concernant d'autres
personnes et d'autres fins que celles et
ceux que nous venons d'expliquer
d'évoquer explicitement
nous n'avons pas mis cette phrase de
manière comme une clause de style il y à
toute une série d'éléments dans le
dossier dans dans le dans le rapport est
aussi dans le document annexé à la
lettre qui peuvent conduire une série
d'investigations
vous comprendrez bien que lorsqu'il ya
des contradictions
on ne sait pas toujours qui a tort et
qui a raison puisqu'ils la contradiction
entre des déclarations
donc il y a trois points différents qui
sont marqués de manière différente
c'est important de le dire le premier
pour deux personnes
le second qui concerne en particulier
trois personnes et le dernier qui
concerne toute personne citée dans le
rapport susceptibles de donner lieu à
des enquêtes à la diligence du parquet
donc nous faisons cela voyez-vous
ensemble en prenant nos responsabilités
et en en ayant conscience vraiment de
faire en conscience ce qui nous est
demandé par la constitution de notre
république
c'est la fin de cette édition merci à
vous de m'avoir suivi tout de suite
suite de nos éditions spéciales affaires
au bénin avec une émission spéciale
présentée par rebecca fitoussi on va
plus loin c'est tout de suite
[Musique]